This is Jocko podcast number
one 21 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
Okay,
I'm going to tell you a story
and this is a story of war
and pain and love and death.
Okay.
And this story.
This is a heroic story,
quite possibly one of the most heroic
stories and at the same time this story is
also a tragedy
and it is quite possibly one of the most
tragic stories.
Yeah.
This is a story of a father and a son.
This is a story that spans six wars
each one more difficult than the next.
This is
a story of life.
We had like all stories of life.
This story ends the way that
all lives and this story
ends in death.
Yeah.
There is no story book ending.
There is no walking off into the sunset.
There is no mercy and no quarter
and no remorse from death.
Okay,
good. As I prepared
to tell this story,
there were times
when I started to decide against it.
Okay.
Where I began to think it would be
too much.
There was another part of me
that spoke louder and spoke stronger
and that other part of me that knows
that to hide from the darkness is only
to allow darkness to grow and I will not
do that.
I will tell this story and this story
that I am going to tell is not just a
story.
It is not made up.
The story is the real story
of the real lives of two men,
two marines,
a father and a son
who fought many battles
both literally hand metaphorically and
who did their best to fight and win
and who we can both learn a lot from,
but we can only learn if we listen.
We can only learn if we study and
we can only learn if we remember
what these men went through,
what they did,
how they lived
and how they died.
I will begin the story with the father.
He is the most famous marine in
the history of the Marine Corps.
He is one of the most highly decorated
men in American military history.
He's the only man ever
awarded five Navy crosses.
His name is Louis Polar,
better known as chesty puller
and he is to most marines
the ultimate marine,
the godfather of the Marine Corps.
To this day,
the mascot of the Marine Corps,
which is a bulldog,
that bulldog is named
chesty after chesty puller.
They're currently on bulldog number 15
named chesty the 15th in bootcamp in
Marine Corps boot camp recruits sing good
night chesty at the end of a long day
he is embedded in the
fiber of the Marine Corps.
Then you might wonder who was this
man and how did he become an icon
to a group that is one of the most
elite fighting forces in the history of
mankind,
the United States Marine Corps.
In order to find out who this man is,
we are going to explore
a book called Marine,
the life of chesty puller
written by Burke Davis
and I will go
to the book.
Louis Burwell Puller was born June 26
to 1898 into a small boys paradise,
the village of West Point Virginia.
We're the [inaudible] monkey and
patrimony rivers form the Broad York.
The waters were full of fish,
crab and oysters,
and the woodlands teamed with game.
Sounds like a good place to grow up.
He often talked to his dream of going
to the Virginia Military Institute and
becoming a soldier from his
reading, his family traditions,
his love of hunting,
fishing and horseback riding.
He was drawn to military life and Vmi.
50 years later at the
end of a fighting career,
he would look back to those days and say,
I learned more in the woods hunting and
stalking about the actual art of war
than I ever learned
any school of any kind.
Yeah.
Those days in the woods as a kid
saved my life many a time in combat.
Okay,
so he wanted to go in the
military from a very young age,
and of course I always have to mention
that I'm going to go very rapidly through
this book.
It may take a while,
but I'm skipping huge parts and
trying to hit the highlights,
but to get the full information,
obviously you need to get the book and
read it yourself. It's a fantastic book.
Back to the book, his effort, his
efforts at translating Caesar.
Okay.
Made him inpatient.
For the true message
of the soldier author.
He was so fascinated by the narrative
of war that he devoured it in one night.
It opened a world,
a new world for him and began a lifelong
career of serious military reading.
It's a common theme we see
with great military leaders.
They read all the time and it started
for him at a young age when he was
translating Caesar.
Okay.
He was captain of the track team.
It's champion Hi Trumper and ran well
in the 100 to 20 and 440 yard dashes.
So he was fairly athletic.
Calvo he's not a big guy.
He was not a big guy when you see
pictures up and he was pretty,
he was relatively small in stature
and he was also relatively, you know,
he wasn't like a bulked up guy.
They and their stories on
why they called him chesty.
The predominant story is, even though he
was small, when he would march in, uh,
on the parade ground,
he would stick his chest out.
So they called them chesty puller
back to the book in the last week of high
school in 1917 the senior class played
hooky one day on the theory,
which proved to be correct that the
principal would not dare expel them all.
Louis was the leader of this prank and
when they returned from a swim and a six
mile hike to the river,
he helped to bring back a dozen
or more bull frogs and paperbacks.
Lewis and Dave field toss the frogs into
a school room window and we're rewarded
by screams and other
sounds of pandemonium.
So He's,
you know,
I had to tell at least one of those
stories that he was a mischievous kid.
You know, a little bit of a rebel.
He enrolled, he did graduate,
enrolled in the military at it Virginia
Military Institute. And back to the book,
Lewis was promoted to Cadet
Corp at the end of the year.
Academically he stood
177 out of 233 cadets.
So, well, not like the
front runner in the class.
His subject standings in his class,
mathematics 200th English 149th German,
130 eighth history a hundred and second
and most significantly military science
89th he had no demerits for the
year and almost unheard of records,
so academically not exactly crushing it,
but military bearing and whatnot.
No demerits. He was doing well.
Now this is where things start
to get a little bit interesting.
Obviously is 1917 so we've got world
war one is going on and here we go.
Back to book.
His chief disappointment was that they
were soldiers without arms for the rifles
were taken by the army
as the war in Europe,
a war on and ammunition had been
too scarce for target practice.
With that,
he said,
I'm going to enlist in the marines.
He said,
I don't want the war to end without me.
I'm going with the rifles if
they need them, they need me to.
On June 27th the day
after his 20th birthday,
Louis took the train to
Richmond and enlisted in the
Marine Corps bound for boot
camp at Paris island,
South Carolina.
So wasn't going to sit around and
let that water run out on him.
Shows up for his a bootcamp.
There's a drill instructor.
Uh,
one of the great things about this book
is the guy that wrote the book of Burke
Davis.
He not only sat down and interviewed
chesty puller for hundreds of hours,
he also went and interviewed all kinds
of people that interacted with Chester
chesty poler during his career,
which he interacted with a lot of people
cause he was in the Marine Corps for a
really long time,
for decades.
And so the book has all kinds of
research and all kinds of interviews.
And one of the people that got
interviewed was the drill instructor,
one of the drill instructors that put
chesty puller through bootcamp drill
instructor. Uh, I think it was
a gunnery Sergeant Desk Bari.
And he said, by God, he's a marine.
He looks as if as if he must sleep
at attention. You always know,
I have to tell him to look mean
and nasty out there marching.
But I never had to tell him.
He's a natural,
he never makes the same mistake twice.
And he talked about, he
talked about polars military
history knowledge. He said,
hell, he gives me an inferiority
complex. I've read some,
but that kid knows von
Clausewitz backwards and guys,
guys I never heard of by the dozen.
He's some kid.
This stuff is like a religion with him.
Okay,
so that's,
that's real stuff right there.
You know we hear General
Maddis talk about that too.
I had general Madison never gets
surprised because he's read it before.
Not going to surprise me
because I already know,
I already seen this situation before.
Maybe not exact,
but I at least have an idea of it.
The non coms admired polars work on
the bayonet field where big signs raid
advanced to kill.
Yeah.
For two months the class went through
intensive drills in the bay bayonet,
that rifle boxing,
judo and infantry drill.
So back in the day, they're still getting
after and a boxing and judo by the way,
is a good combination, very good
combination. You get your take downs,
you get your grappling
and you get some striking.
One day the men were told that their
orders had come and they were packed to
leave for Hoboken New Jersey
to ship out for France.
Okay.
Being meaning they were going to war.
The move was postponed for several days
until armistice day canceled the orders.
So the end of the war came.
He was detached and sent to the
third officer's training school,
so they took him and said, you know
what, you did so good in bootcamp.
The war's over, we don't have orders.
We're going to send you to be an officer.
Back to the book,
He became a second lieutenant on June
4th two weeks later when he had finished
machine gun school,
the end of the war brought a huge cut in
the marine corps on June 16th polar was
discharged with hundreds of others
of his rank and he was at loose ends.
He'd been a marine officer for two weeks.
Okay.
Now as he's kind of processing out,
he met a guy named Captain Route Curtis
at the Marine Corps headquarters and
this is what the advice he gave him.
You know,
he sees this young hard charger and says,
if I were you, I'd go down to Haiti.
You'll get commissions in the,
in the constabulary down there and they
need good men and there's plenty of
fighting.
You'd see action and have some fun.
So at this point in Haiti,
they had basically built this, uh, this,
it's,
it should,
John Dahl has,
where's gendarmerie is what they call it,
but it's a military force.
Yeah.
That also does police work kind of.
So,
and there was a, there was a revolution
in Haiti. There were issues in Haiti.
And so America actually invaded Haiti in
1915 and now they had established this
forced to keep things under control.
And the way they did it,
it was run, they took the,
the locals and they put,
basically hired former marines
to be in charge of them.
And then the goal was as the locals,
the,
the native Haitians w started
to understand military
operations and they would
get promoted and the American
marines and soldiers could go home.
That was the plan. So let's see. Um,
kind of just covered this,
but Haiti was strife,
was the strife of war torn
western tip of the island,
shared with Dominican Republic.
Revolutions had been shaking
the government since 1914
after almost a century of
freedom from France since 1916 at the
request of the Haitian government,
marines had police the
country I made violence,
which had taken nearly 2000 lives,
almost all Haitian General Smedley,
Smedley Butler who will get to sometime
on this podcast had created the John
Dahl, Marie the Haiti with a straw
with a shrewd disregard for precedent.
The senior officers where US Marine
officers whose brief tours of two years
created a supply of
field trained commanders.
But he chose the marine enlisted men to
act as junior officers and allowed them
to stay as long as they wish on the
theory that they became more valuable as
they learned the language and
customs of the people in practice.
It was these marines, these marines
enlisted men who operated the force
under them were many native soldiers,
most of them veterans of the old
Haitian army. And from this pool,
they were drawn second lieutenants
and sergeants and corporals.
So that's what you have. That's the
situation. So he deploys down there,
he's not really in the Marine
Corps is a hired hand basically.
Um,
so now he's there,
not for very long and back to the
book about 4:00 PM without warning.
Louis stumbled into the
first fight of his career,
improved his instinct for combat,
the pack train, this is a group,
he was moving the,
a group of people through the woods.
The packed train was ambling around
a wooded bet bend between hills,
which were littered with stones and
cactus when in met an oncoming Keiko band.
This is the,
the revolutionaries,
I guess you call them the [inaudible]
band of about a hundred equally surprised.
And at the end in the same formation,
polar sport has spurred his
horse and yelled charge,
attack the column,
charged horses,
pack meals and all.
And in the funder and dust,
fierce gels of the cake goes broke for
the hills firing a few stray rounds.
So that was kind of his first combat
experience. You got to bring that up.
Uh,
but
he was default aggressive
even in an logistics movement.
You know, they've got a bunch of
pack horses and he's like, oh charge.
And it worked
back to the book. Another situation that
he gets into from the opposite shore,
a native and Dominican dress
rode out on a magnificent horse,
a big buck skin with white mane and tail
who splashed through the shallows under
perfect control though, without a
bridle or saddle, a wonderful horse.
Polar said, I'd surely
like to have him. Bruno,
who's one of the guys,
one of the natives that that was working
under him moderate and creole and a
rifle cracked polar saw one of his men
pull his rifle bolt back and reject a
cartridge.
The beautiful horse stood in the river
looking nervous about his rider floated
down the stream in a stain of blood.
The stunned polar turned to Bruno.
Did you order that man shot?
Hell Sir. You said you wanted the horse.
Anything the captain says is our command.
We have discipline here sir.
The man seemed unmoved by the cold
blooded killing my God. Catch the horse,
get the men over the river. And see if
you can find that man's family. And this,
the reason I pulled this
out is this line right here,
Lewis never again expressed himself. I'd
lead before these soldiers. So that's,
that's a crazy story, right? He
says all that's a beautiful horse.
I'd love to have that horse. And they
kill the horse riders. Just a civilian.
But he realized the power
that you have in command.
And there's sometimes when people don't
realize that people don't realize how I
run into that with business leaders.
They'll walk around,
all this is this is crap and everyone
thinks it's crap then or you know,
do you got to realize that
your words have meaning.
And when you're in a senior position,
your words have power.
And so that was how he learned that
listen to in a very horrible way,
back to the book company aid weighted
the Stream without opposition.
But as they mounted the rich beyond a
rifle fired and there was a terrifying
shriek of a boat overhead.
Polar duct.
Lieutenant Lee was at his side and said,
Captain Polar Officers do not
flinch under fire. They stand,
the men take note of this thing.
It is of first importance.
So he's going to get plenty of exercise
in that and you'll see he becomes well
known for never flinching
again under fire.
Here's something about the people they
were fighting these Keiko bandits.
They carry off everybody and every wounded
man and when they catch our wounded,
well captain,
if you see one,
you'll never forget the Kaikos believe
every man who dies must go before the
gods and they use their knives
to see that when our men go,
they are beyond recognition.
They slashed the face to ribbons
and tear of the body apart.
You will see captain,
it's a matter of life or death for the
officers and noncommissioned officers
here to respect,
to have respect from the men
and something more adulation.
They must obey orders to the letter.
Without question though, they die for it.
It was the only way to handle
men in combat. If you lose
control, you lose lives.
It is as simple as that.
So there you see the super strict
discipline that they're into.
And this is something that you're going
to see this theme throughout the book
that chesty has this,
this reputation which is earned
of being super hard core.
But also in the book you're gonna see
over and over again that there's a huge
dichotomy that he's super hardcore,
but at the same time he knows when
he needs to give people slack.
He knows when he needs to be a positive
reinforcement instead of a negative one.
And his rep is reputation, doesn't have
that. But that line right there like,
hey, they just need to do
whatever you say. He doesn't
even believe that, but it's,
it's pointed out.
And so I brought it up because
the contradiction becomes
pretty clear or not the
contradiction, but the dichotomy
is very clear throughout this book.
So back to the book General John,
a lagoon commandant of the corps had
come to Haiti on inspection and Louis was
anxious to see the hero
of the fighting in France.
And Camp Lejune isn't called
Camp Lajune for nothing.
And at this point a marine patrol
filed pass. And this is a good another,
another good lesson.
They were unshaven and
ill kempt I'm afraid to,
men are a little ragged
and out of uniform sir.
And the company commander Clinton said,
I'm trying to improve them.
Colonel, I'm a field soldier. Lazoon said,
I don't give a damn what
men look like in the field.
The only one thing interests
me and that's ending this war.
Don't waste your time shining
them up for jungle work.
Our only objective is
success and I demand that.
So there's a contradiction right there.
Like we'll not a contradiction,
but there's the dichotomy and
he's hearing it from now on.
The other side is here in this room from
a general the June who's saying, look,
I don't care what these
guys look like in the field.
You don't need to polish them up. They
need to when they need to be fighting.
And chesty puller becomes very famous
for the way he appears sometimes in the
field. Meaning he's not exactly
spit and Polish out there.
He was awarded the medal military
air of the Republic of Haiti and
he did not go unnoticed by his superiors.
And early in 1921 he was a recommended
for a permanent commission in the Marine
Corps,
whereas rank was now that have sergeant,
he served as a judge adjutant
to Colonel Vandergriff.
This is another famous marine.
He again became a second lieutenant US
Marine Corps, but this time as irregular,
I may not have much else to go on. He told
a friend, but I have some perseverance.
He had fought in 40 actions in Haiti.
He developed his instinct.
He developed his instinct of talent for
using terrain and battle and learn the
lessons of jungle fighting.
He becomes strongly prejudiced against
barracks and headquarters soldiers.
Despite his youth.
He was one of the most combat
seasoned combat officers into core.
So he got noticed because
he did well in combat.
He eventually gets,
gets up,
hired on into the Marine Corps as a
sergeant and then very quickly thereafter
goes back to the officer ranks after
he's working for our colonel Vandergriff.
So there you go.
And you can see he develops this prejudice
against barracks and headquarters
soldiers.
Rear Echelon is what we call them
now.
After he came back to the states,
he gets chosen to run the the Marine
Corps drill team who has apparently
competing and they hadn't been winning
against the navy and the army and the
coast guard teams. They've, they've
been beating them and so he takes over.
So here we go. Private Bob Nourish a
company clerk drafted for the detachment,
shared the astonishment of his mates.
The lieutenant told us the first day
that we would bring home the cop or die
trying and from the cold I, he gave
us, we believed it. We found out.
We found we weren't mistaken.
He took,
he took out the silent drill manual
and started this from scratch.
He drove us day after day until we figured
we'd never lived to see Boston when
he was through with us.
We literally thought as if we had one
head instead of 80 yet somehow though he
was hard as nails,
he could be as friendly.
You can be friendly with us like
no other officer we'd ever seen.
We gave them all we had. So there
you go. Driving people hard,
but they love him and they
love him because he treats
them with respect and he's
nice to him.
And that's the dichotomy and he f he
knows instinctively how to walk that line
and that dichotomy. Leadership back
to the book a few weeks afterwards,
polar was whisked off to his next duty
station assigned as a flying cadet in
Pensacola,
Florida,
a chance which he had been pleading
since its first flights and he improvised
Jenny bomber hatery.
So I didn't cover this part in the book,
but when he was in Haiti he did like
flights and dropped grenades on enemy
locations and he was into it and he
gets down to Pensacola and fails his two
solo tests and he left Pensacola
disappointed and interestingly three years
after he,
after this happened,
he tried to reapply.
And this is an interesting comment,
the medical board in Washington in
answer to his plea for one more chance,
found him physically fit to fly but not
temperamentally adapted for aviation
training.
So That's interesting.
You know that this guy who's
obviously a great combat leaders,
didn't have whatever the whatever
they were looking for for flying.
He didn't have it and he
made multiple attempts.
MMM.
When he went back home for a little while,
he went to a dance and there's some sort
of interesting fact that that's the way
they did it. Back in the day, you know,
hey, we're going to go to a dance,
and he met a woman named Virginia Evans.
He dance with her three
times with fumbling attempts
at conversation during the
next dance. He made up his mind. His
manner became assured, will you marry me?
She laughed.
Heavens no.
How can I do that when I haven't
even finished the school? You will.
He spent the night in the stag
line watching and dancing her.
She noticed that he danced with
no other girl after that meeting.
He did not see her again
for almost 11 years,
but he never lifted the long range seat,
gets his mind committed
to something in Virginia.
Evans was what he was committed to.
He gets shipped off to Hawaii in
July of 1926 when he shows up there.
Another interesting story,
Louis held firm discipline and its company
and some men were probably resentful
until they learned that he spared
himself less than he did others.
He was ruthless with violators of
safety precautions where firearms were
involved and every time a man shot a
weapon on the base without good reason,
the fine was automatically
$20 one day on inspection,
polar saw a 45 in the guard house,
picked it up,
release the clip and pulled
the slide and the trigger.
The gun fired unexpectedly in a bullet,
furrowed into the ceiling.
Chesty Puller had an AED,
an accidental discharge.
Though he had taken all the precautions
except to look in the firing chamber,
polar find himself $100 which he gave
to the guards to buy beer for liberty
party.
He bombarded headquarters with pleased
to send them to Nicaragua where war had
broken out and marines. We're trying
to put down a native bandit uprising,
so wars going on in Nicaragua and
he says, Hey, send me down there.
Back to the book. Nicaragua adds even
more rugged than hated than Haiti.
The Green Rolling Country of jungle and
planes dominated by towering highlands
upon which we're tumbled.
Mountain masses. For many years,
revolutions had torn the land
despite the presence of US Marines.
And now a bitter new war had
called them back after a year.
His absence in the north
lay at unconquered Indian
empire whose people did not
recognize the central government and
there where he moved back and forth across
the border of Honduras
was the rebel chief.
Augustus Augusto Caesar Sandino.
Yeah.
So that's what's going on in Nicaragua.
Okay.
Chesty poler shows up, reported to
general e are beetle, and he says,
I'll give you a company up
in the Sago vs in the north.
I understand you like to mix it up.
Big Mix up, big, mix it up.
So this is, again, you know this,
there's so many things that he does that
just build this incredible reputation
that he ends up with.
And here's one of them.
The native Voss with a f was a fire eating
brigand who had been appointed as the
local HEFY.
Half a politico
holler invaded his office,
accompanied by a sergeant and in brief
words told the terrorists that he would,
that he had come to restore order and
that trouble trouble makers would be,
would fare badly.
He ended quietly.
You will be held responsible for
any further disorder with your life.
As he talked,
he saw partially open drawer in the
desk before the chief and the bow of a
revolver. The boss looked as if he
wanted to snatch the pistol. Go ahead.
Polar said, use it if you can.
We'll settle this once and for all.
You'd better be fast.
Like
who does that? I'll tell you who
does that chesty puller. Does that
pull polars career as a guerrilla fighter
now opened in earnest in February,
1930 he was ordered to clear bandits
from the area of San Antonio. Bill Lee,
who had earlier served
three years in Nicaragua,
had been pleading for a chance to return.
Lee was a tall,
muscular athlete from Massachusetts
who had been 16 years and the corn was
conditioned by years of
playing fullback on the team,
have a coal burning coal
burning battleship and by
boxing and pulling an oar on
a crew puller,
unhesitatingly chose him to help direct
company m and Lee and Lewis found and
Lee found Lewis an ideal commander.
This is,
this is classic. He, this is what
Lee says about his commander,
which is chesty puller.
He never really gave me orders.
He just told me what headquarters wanted,
asked me if I knew the country
and to get up the men we needed.
He was a common sense officer and you
always knew where you stood with him when
he was displeased about
something I'd done.
He never chewed me out as so many
inexperienced officers would have done.
He would say, if I had been doing
that, I'd have done it this way.
Yeah,
and that would be the end of it. We got
all my brothers most important of all.
He was not green.
When he first came to Nicaragua,
Haiti had taught them jungle fighting
and he took the to the new country like a
native.
That paragraph right there is just,
it's so important,
especially again,
when people get the image of a marine
and of chesty puller that he's just going
to whip everyone into shape. Like
no, that's not a good leader.
That is not a good leader.
Back to the book,
General Magee Mcdougal recommended polar
for a navy cross citing five fights
against, so this is after he's
been there for a little sighting,
five fights and get superior
numbers without loss to himself.
The nine known enemy dead and numerous
but uncounted wounded and the impressive
loot of munitions, an animal's food
and captured military dispatches.
The recommendation ended ended thus by
his intelligent and forceful leadership
without thought of his own personal
safety by great physical exertion and by
suffering many hardships.
He surmounted all obstacles and dealt
five successive and severe blows against
organized banditry and
the Republic of Nicaragua.
So there you go. That's what he's
getting after down in Nicaragua.
Here's a another captain,
he Lindsey [inaudible],
who was the intelligence officer in the,
in the marine brigade.
He saw that some of the
people were jealous, so he,
so he started getting a little bit famous.
People started writing about them.
There was an article in the New York
Times about them and people started having
some professional
jealousy back to the book.
This is Lynn sat talking now and then
from New York Times now and then the New
York Times got some of these stories
from Nicaraguan papers and polars name
became widely known.
A few officers around headquarters who
thought of themselves as clouds of types,
muttered criticisms of polar and
said he was a publicity hound.
I knew that the opposite was true and
that Louis spent virtually his whole life
in this period on the trail
deepened enemy country.
While our staff officer friends,
sob sat on their duffs in the
cities far removed from the warfare,
but you get that professional jealousy.
There's a classic example of it.
Here's a General Julien Smith
talking about Louis Polar.
He was probably the
bravest man I ever knew.
His was a cool courage.
Not One of desperation about the only
way to contact the enemy there was to let
them ambush him.
He would go anywhere without support
knowing that if he got in a jam,
he had to get himself out. He never
hesitated. He invited that kind of work.
He's getting after it.
Uh, he went home for a little while.
He visited his younger brother,
Sam, who is also a second
lieutenant in the marine corps,
and then polar landed in one
of the army infantry schools.
The armature,
he army's infantry school.
He went to that school while he was there,
sometimes had some
disagreements with the staff.
Here's one.
One lecturer told the students that
volume of fire in the field was more
important than accuracy that
brought polar to his feet.
You must have forgotten what happened
in the American revolution. He said,
we won that war with accurate fire.
When the enemy had all the volume it
wanted king's mountain and Saratoga and
every other battle we won,
and real shooting almost whipped the mass
firing federal army in the civil war.
It's still like that anywhere.
I've seen men shooting it out.
You don't hurt them if you don't hit him.
Great Point. Even though suppressive
fires, awesome and massive volume of fire,
definitely. We'll keep the enemy
down. Heads down. You got to hit him.
That's,
you know I've talked about this before
but that's like why in Ramadi our machine
gunners were putting, put, putting
scopes on their machine guns, which is,
I mean they're part of partially doing
it for to be able to identify who they
were looking at positively identify enemy
looking for weapons cause you've got a
little magnification on your scope.
But still they also wanted to like
hit what they were shooting at.
Obviously our snipers riflemen
were doing that too. But yeah,
you got to hit what's your, you got
to hit so you got to hit the bad guys.
Yeah.
Back to the book. And as he was at Ben,
he was at that school at, at Fort Benning,
Louis left bending with many
new friends and all services.
But most important carried away a
distrust of overscheduling military men.
Here's polar talking.
The trouble with this school business
is that we've taken it too far.
We sit around in classrooms and we'll,
the conditions of battle, of course,
an actual battle. You can't,
we'll anything, not a damn thing,
because the enemy will do what you don't
want him to do or expect them to do
almost every time.
Then the results of actual warfare
studied back in the schools,
the staff officers and planners most
in most of whom have never seen real
battles. Wonder what went
wrong with their neat plants.
You just simply cannot learn warfare in
a school room or anywhere else except in
combat,
and you'll never know whether you're a
fighting man until you're under fire.
Yeah,
he goes back to Nicaragua after that.
Okay.
Back to the book.
Throughout the latter half of 1932
company M was on unceasing patrol,
averaging 18 to 20 miles
daily on the mountain trails,
stretching it some days too,
as much as 40 miles
polar and Lee and their troops marched
more than 10,000 miles in the Nicaragua
fighting always on foot for the early
discovered that horseman drew fire in
every skirmish,
and so they walked without the
mark of officer on their uniforms.
Okay.
10,000 miles.
On schedule on January 20 on January 2nd,
1933 the marines began leaving Nicaragua.
Yeah.
In February,
okay.
Louis was introduced to
military society and peaking
okay.
At the u s legation,
his commander pinned on his chest,
the Star for the navy cross
you'd want to Nicaragua. So he,
he won another navy cross.
Less than a month later he
took over the Horse Marines.
Louis discovered that the 600 man,
u s marine battalion held only one field
exercise each week and this was called
off in extreme heat or
cold or a dust storm,
but that the Japanese did not cancel
their training marches for any reason.
He put his horse marines
through their paces daily,
excluding Saturdays and Sundays,
leading them on long cross country rides
with small dust storms boiling in their
wake.
He wrote into areas where Japanese,
we're training in an effort to observe
their details and our tactical work.
So he came home and take over and we're
just going to tighten things up a little
bit. One training exercise
a month? No, daily.
We're switching to daily. Back to the
book. Lewis never forgot Virginia Evans.
That was the girl from the dance and
faithfully wrote her of his experiences in
China.
In one letter,
he wrote so emphatically that you could
almost see him blurting out the words he
wanted to hear.
He wanted to say to her,
but dear, even if you do marry me
and make me a happy man, even then,
if I hear the beat of the drum, I must
leave you. I want you to know that
she's not even married to him yet.
She's not even married to him yet.
And he's like, Hey, you know, that's great
if you marry me and make me happy, man,
that's awesome.
But if I hear that beat of the drum,
I'm out going to do what I gotta do.
Okay,
here's another he,
he got in trouble.
He got in trouble a lot because
he didn't hold his tongue
and you're supposed to hold
your tongue, right? And he did.
That's why so many people loved him.
It's also why he got professional jealousy
and it's also why he got in trouble
sometimes. Here's one example. Example.
Polar was aware of some American military
errors on board the Augusta and he
never failed to expose them and
talks with his, with his intimates.
Here we have a 10,000 ton heavy cruiser
with about 800 men aboard just one on
the Asiatic station.
The British have three
cruisers on duty here.
You ever notice that we have
37 typewriters on this ship?
The British have just one machine
on each of their cruisers.
Why do you suppose that is?
You know damn well they don't read all
those reports back in Washington when
they get their paperwork
will ruin any military force.
They should have learned
that from Smedley Butler.
They'll shed this monstrosity
when war comes though.
And the fighting people will take over.
So he doesn't like the paperwork. He
doesn't eat any. You can see he does.
The people that haven't fought,
that's who he's talking about.
People that don't fight,
they're the people that create paperwork
cause they don't understand how
negative and affects everyone.
So they create this stupid paperwork and
he ends up going to the basic school,
which is like the officer where the
officers sort of get trained in all the
fundamental principles of combat.
Hmm.
For the Marine Corps. And he ended up
being an instructor there. Here we go.
Back to the book. This is coming
from a guy named Lou. Walt
polar was my commander and to me was
the epitome of what the Murray of what
Marine Corps training should do.
Not only in weapons or
classroom or field training.
He gave us everything hard at every break
in the field though he drove us until
our tongues were hanging out.
Men still gathered around him.
He told us tales about fighting in Haiti
and Nicaragua of this patrols living
off the land and fighting natives.
All his experiences,
not just guff.
Every tail had some point.
Being under polar in basic school did
more for me than anything I experienced
until I got to Guadalcanal.
He taught us use of terrain,
like a master, how to use the tiniest
bit of covered it to our advantage.
Ground form really meant
something when he explained it.
He taught us to use the Bayer net with
all the tricks of close in fighting.
You couldn't mistake it. He
knew his stuff cold. So again,
classic example of when People Think,
Oh,
if I'm nicer and I take
it easy on the truth,
they'll like me more like wrong answer.
Hmm.
Wrong answer.
Back to the book on a freezing rain
swept day just before polars marriage,
the class of 1937 it had an uncomfortable
experience with him on the drill field
they wore nor no overcoats as
they marched. Teeth shattered,
but the ranks moved with precision.
Lewis saw stray glances at
the barracks detachment,
which came out for a brief drill
wrapped and heavy overcoats and then
disappeared.
Those our barracks marines,
he said with a z with
an edge in his voice,
your fighting marines being completed,
the full schedule for the day,
chilled to the bone and soaking wet.
So legit,
that's it's solid yet.
And he got married and here we go.
The pullers left the pleasant life of
Philadelphia Navy Yard in the spring of
1939 nine bound for the Orient.
They had a few days in Hawaii and went
to Waikiki one morning to ride surfboards
with another young friend,
Lieutenant Gordon Warner,
a champion swimmer who had studied
under Louis at the basic school.
The two men went out to see in a
canoe and to Virginia's astonishment,
Lewis road in with Wagner balancing with
his balancing with skill as rollers.
Harold them towards the shore.
Lewis then returned and rode in on a
surf board alone and turned to Virginia.
Come on,
you're going to try it too.
You never had so much fun chesty
puller getting some of that stoke.
Awesome. I just had to
bring that out, right.
Even chesty puller like
there's a little bit of stoke.
Hmm.
Back to the book with a little further
delay. Lewis got what he saw for himself.
He would report to the new Marine base
in North Carolina swamp lands at River
where he would command the first battalion
seventh marines and prepare them for
war. So obviously Pearl Harbor takes
place and he heads back to the states to
takeover the one seven marines
were the battalion returned
from the field late afternoon.
Polar called a conference of his company
officers. Gentlemen, my name's polar,
your new commander. We have a
good deal of work to do together.
I'll be slow to make changes,
but one of them begins tomorrow at the
first rest period after we leave camp
camouflage every man and
every piece of equipment,
we've got no camouflage material.
Major. Well Dude. Anyways,
the best is in the field.
Find a mod whole smear motto and your
face is enhance twigs on helmets and
blouses. Anywhere you can stick them.
Pine foliage is good, you'll learn.
The battalion began with
marches of 12 miles daily.
Okay.
This was pushed to 15 and then 20 miles.
Pull her punctuated drills
with fight talks to his men.
Okay.
They were very young. Many of them. Beard,
this boys under 16 who must
have lied about their ages.
They were the most obscene. The
profane men polar had ever encountered.
Edward L.
Smith,
a young battalion doctor educated at
Yale and Harvard confessed that the
constant flow of filthy
language actually sick and him.
Okay.
Now we had some guys that were marching
and some of them followed fallout from
the heat and he wrote it and
the major polar comes by.
When you were marching this morning I
heard a marine or the roadside say there
goes the God damn seventh regiment.
I was amazed.
One of you didn't step out of
ranks and knock him out cold.
Okay.
One of his privates, Gerald Wyatt,
a Yale man from Eastport Maine,
also a diarist began to take note
of polar. He is never obscene.
Remarkably for the vigor with which he
handles us. He has toughened demands,
the outmost,
but there was always a kindly approach
even when he is chewing you out,
the displays a touching sympathy.
Again,
this is what, this is what we're trying
to do as leaders. Balance that dichotomy.
Hmm.
Here's polar talking to his troops.
One more thing.
Whenever we are at Chow,
the privates will be fed first.
Then the non coms and officer's last of
all typical taking care of the troops
when they were toughing to that. Oh,
this is it. When they're there. Um,
okay.
Doing Calisthenics and all their marches
and here we go back to the book when
they were tough to that polar put
them through a series of night marches
beginning after midnight.
The doctor's like others learn to read
maps and campuses and to handle weapons,
including mortars. The practice
of identifying ships and planes.
A joke in most units
became a serious business.
In one seven some medics
learned Morse Code and Manila,
John Basel owned an army trained veteran
machine gunner traded semaphore lessons
for instruction and first aid.
Okay.
Had to bring up that we had Manila John.
It's like unbelievable man that this
stories are just unbelievable.
Here's,
here's another very cool a situation.
This young lieutenant was practicing
some kind of an assault and he gets a
little complicated and and polars what
pulled our calls. Everyone is old man.
Whether they're older than him or younger,
he calls everyone old man,
which is pretty funny. So here we go.
Paul was talking to this young lieutenant,
old man, there's mighty little room
for fancy tackers below division level,
the enemy or on the hill. You go get
them. In the end you'll save men.
There are times when
you will have to flank,
but don't forget that the shortest
distance between two points is a straight
line.
Get some.
I always talk about flanking
and I'm a big believer,
Jesse polar says, hey,
sometimes you've got to flank,
but sometimes you got to
go get some straight line.
Here's another important
thing. He, there's a,
there's a a colonel that's
running artillery training
and he goes and talks to
him. Colonel, you'll be starting
artillery training next week.
I want you to let me know when,
when your fire,
I want to get my troops under it as
often as I can and the colonel said there
may be accidents and fuller
says we can chance those.
What I won't chance is taking a bunch of
green kids to war before they know the
sound of big guns. I know shells aren't
the same going in and coming out,
but this will help.
Okay,
so he wanted to get down, right?
They're all under the sound of the guns.
Hmm. Lieutenant Cox. Now,
the executive of a company was
impressed by pro polars thoroughness.
Major polar never stood aside and said,
carry on sergeant,
and most often other officers did.
He was in there with us packing all.
He could walk down the best of us,
even the kids, other commanders,
road cars in the woods,
but not polar.
Okay,
here's another journal entry private
Gerald White wrote for his diary.
Polar must've marched twice the
distance we did for all day long.
He kept marching up and down the column.
John as a Bantam Rooster,
pipe clinched in his teeth.
Ever alert to see that,
who to see that men who were succumbing
to the heat exhaustion or blisters were
taken care of by Korman many
times today I saw him take a bar,
which is browning automatic rifle.
It's a big machine gun, a bar machine,
gun or mortar off the shoulder of some
marine who's Fannie was dragging and
carry it to give the
poor guy some respites.
Here's another situation again,
good dichotomy here.
Somebody that he finds somebody
asleep on watch, which by the way,
it's like an incredibly horrible thing,
which you can get severely punished for.
Back to the book,
polar shook the boy wake old man.
It's dangerous to pull a trick like this.
Suppose captain Rogers had caught you eat,
made a big fuss,
and then I'd have to court martial
you and slap you into the brick.
Maybe that's what I should do.
But I'll give you another chance.
Pretty soon now we'll
be fighting for keeps
and you'll still stay awake or
risk the lives of every one of us.
You understand me?
So I mean talk about it.
Way To endear yourself to the
troops. That's so awesome. Hey,
if the cap mortar caught you,
then would have been a big fuss.
Luckily I caught you.
Polar was,
so they deployed overseas.
Okay.
Polar was promoted to
lieutenant colonel on Samoa.
He wrote to his wife.
Okay.
Life is so short.
Yeah.
And when I was a child,
I thought it would last forever and ever.
Yeah.
My love for you will Virginia
even into the next life.
And then on the hardest thing that
I've ever done was tell you goodbye.
That was a black Tuesday and I pray
they will never be another separation.
Yeah, you're not right. You know they're
going, they're heading into a Guadalcanal,
so that's going to make everyone
think life can get pretty short.
Hm.
Back to the book.
Fire came from the sea where Japanese
ships stood close in on challenged and
battered the area.
Much of the grove was cone by flying
fragments and men screamed in agony.
Trees were torn and broken and
many tumbled to the ground.
Okay.
People reported hearing general
polar or at this time colonel polar.
It's all right man. Stay down and they
can't hurt you. This won't last forever.
Tomorrow will be our turn,
so they're just getting paid.
Landed on the beach and they're
just getting hammered with
Jap from Japanese ships.
Big artillery from the big naval guns.
Okay.
The battalion left that left
the perimeter that afternoon.
A file of more than 800 men.
Okay.
The tail of the battalion had
hardly cleared the perimeter
when there was firing
ahead. Captain Hayes was near
the colonel. At the moment.
Every man hit the deck except Pauler.
Yeah.
We dive for the growth beside the trail,
but he walked up and down the line
talking as if he were on parade.
He told us it was all right,
and this has nothing to worry about.
Just small stuff. We began to
get up again. Then in there,
he commanded that battalion as it
never imagined it could be commanded.
Okay.
The men saw what kind of man they had
and the word went down the column as fast
as light.
We lost our fear or some of it
on a grassy knoll above the tangle
where the Knights Bivouac was planned.
The call column met an ambush to
Bob Haggerty's platoon were killed.
Two of Bob Haggerty's platoon were
killed and the unit broken a tiny groups
leaving Haggerty without a command.
He lane cover and watched polar.
It was the greatest exhibition of utter
disregard for Personal Safety I ever saw.
He definitely,
like I said,
whatever that officer was in Haiti that
told them, don't show fear under fire.
He took that one to the bank.
Okay.
Back to the book of runner.
Just be this. Again,
I'm jumping around just from
different combat scenarios.
A runner just behind polar was hit
in the throat and died quickly.
Everyone else hit the ground
except for colonel polar.
First Sergeant William Pennington
retained a vivid memory of the moment.
The colonel stood there and that grazing
fire with that little old stump of a
pipe in his face yelling be company.
Second platoon in line,
hear machine gun fire kicked up,
dust all around me and I stayed down in
that knee high Kunai grass like everyone
else in the ranks.
He was the only marine you could
see standing on that hillside.
Get this. Here we go. A
grenade fell near the old man.
No more than eight yards away.
Captain Sat,
Captain Zach Cox estimated but polar
turned when he saw a company scatter and
yelled,
oh that damn thing ain't going off.
It helped to steady the men.
The grenade was a dud.
Yeah,
so they get done.
They're kind of like a situation.
First few days of
fighting back to the book.
Polars battalion had
24 dead and 23 wounded.
The next day back into main
defense line of the perimeter.
He called together the
battalion officer's.
His voice was hard and his
face on smiling. Gentlemen,
at least we've all been blooded.
Now,
I don't want you to be mooning over our
losses and feeling sorry for yourselves
or taking all the blame on your shoulders.
We've all got to leave this world someday.
We're all in the same pickle.
Then there are worse things
than dying for your country.
Some things about our action
in the last four days,
I want you to remember forever.
There are some we'd all like to forget,
but there'll be in your mind's
eye as long as you live.
I hope we've all learned something now.
Take care of your men and make yourselves
ready. We haven't seen anything yet.
One other thing back there on
the hillside at Mount Austin,
I had trouble getting company officers up.
I hope you saw that costs us casualties.
Never do.
I want to see that again in my command.
I want to see officers leading.
I want you to know that your
leaders and not simply commanders,
you cannot operate a military force in
the field under these conditions with
commanders alone. Civilians wouldn't
know what I was talking about,
but you found out now that it's true,
there aren't many qualities in a man,
but one that is absolutely necessary
in an infantry leader is stark courage.
Give that idea to your
men and your own way.
Don't worry over the things that are done
that we can no longer help concentrate
on building a better combat uner unit
because that's the best hope of all of us
surviving.
None of us could help the fact that I
was the only combat train man and our
outfit when we began. I was lucky
enough to get the jolt when I was young.
You'll come along fast and
there'll be work for us.
Let's be ready when our time comes.
Yeah, that's, that's, that's,
I haven't really heard that
point, but you know what?
You need to hear people talk
about leaders and managers,
and I've worked with companies in it and
it's a good, a good sentiment, right? Hey,
RP, our leaders aren't our leaders, our
leaders, they're not managers. Yeah.
Well this is an interesting one of say,
look, it's not not commanders, leaders,
not commanders,
and that if you think about the
difference between commander's meeting,
I'm going to come in and you want to
do is I'm going to lead the very, very
cool,
uh,
distinction between those two words.
Back to the book. He still missed
nothing involving the morale of his men,
Reagan Fuller,
who began to feel the stark drama of the
situation after the first severe fight
grew a beard and swaggered around the
perimeter like a desperado polar took him
aside. Oh man, you're carried
away with this war business.
You're feeling too self important
about it. That's dangerous.
This is just a matter
of kill or be killed.
I got to read that again.
This is just a matter of kill or be killed
and we've got to stay on our toes to
have a chance. Clean yourself
up. Here's some shaving gear.
And when you're through, you can take
a drink from that bottle if you like.
Again,
like
connecting with your troops
and recognizing that a
guy starting to do like go
sideways a little bit and pull
him aside and talking to them.
Okay,
all right. Now again, they're
just engaged in a fierce battle.
This point back to the book at the peak
of this polar had a telephone call from
the regimental commander
in the rear polar.
We've got to change in order to
execute a reconnaissance enforced.
When your battalion along the coast
road do not become involved in a large
action, be prepared to withdraw
to maintain communications.
Reagan fuller was within earshot
of polar as polar shouted in rage.
How the hell can I make a reconnaissance
when we're engaged down to the last man,
we're fighting tooth and nail.
Man,
if you'd get off your duff and
come up here where the fighting is,
you could the situation.
Boom.
Again,
this is why he wasn't always super
popular up the chain of command because he
spoke the truth sometimes in the most,
not the most tactful way.
Yeah.
Now polars battalion actually ends up
getting the upper hand there and he gets
them kind of pin down in.
Okay.
Crushes him back to the book when it was
over the regimental headquarters called
back relieving polar of any necessity of
a reconnaissance patrol and permitting
him to return to the perimeter.
There was also a call from Hannah Akin,
a request to bring back is wounded polars
men carried in all casualties from the
two battalion.
Two Battalions Pours Battalion
had five dead and 21 wounded.
Total losses were 65 dead in
125 wounded for the operation.
Polar estimated that the enemy losses
to be at least five times that that,
but it was later revealed
that the Japanese fourth
infantry had lost almost an
entire battalion with 690 dead.
The result of polar strike in the crater.
Okay.
Now,
like I said,
he speaks his mind and
remember I mentioned Colonel
Vandergriff who we worked
for when he was a young lieutenant,
will now have a colonel.
Vandergriff is a general and general
Vandergriff that they're having a little
conversation back to the book.
The whole process was asinine.
The mixed up outfits as
badly as they possibly could.
There was no overall commander division
gave orders to skin wailing and me.
Whaling was senior,
but orders did not come through him.
My regimental commander was
behind the river and not on scene.
Thus when they found two battalion
stopped cold in the fight,
communications were so bad.
They pulled these two outfits and left
me to face all the enemy. We were blind,
lucky to come out as we did.
Imagine them ordering me to go on some
damn reconnaissance when I was fighting
with every man I had.
Proper designation of authority would
have made everything clear. Boom.
There you go. Yup. Proper
designation of authority.
People need to know who's in charge
and you need to put someone in charge.
That's the way it's got to work.
Hmm. When you don't have that,
you get confused and you get issues.
Now there's a,
there's like a field doctor there.
Dr. Smith noted in his diary that pullers
seemed more concerned over losses.
He's become almost fanatical and his
desire to see that men are properly cared
for.
If a man's body has lost,
he is greatly disturbed and frets about
the time lost before he can recover the
body and give it a decent burial.
There you go.
There was one on pleasant matter,
a young Philadelphian who had earlier
been a disciplinary problem on Samoa,
had failed the colonel on the crater
march, polar called Jim Hayes,
the legal officer.
I want you to have hers
tried for dereliction of duty
in the face of the enemy.
He threw away his load a mortar shells
because it was too heavy and he costs me
the lives of several men.
Damn his time.
I'll draw a recommendation.
I'm going to have him shot.
Okay.
And I don't think I cover it.
It's it.
The reason I pointed that out or I
covered that is cause that guy redeems
himself in the future. And it's one
of the times where polar says, okay,
you're good. He does some
incredibly brave and crazy things.
All right, so here we
go. Back to the book.
The major Japanese attack was expected.
What's expected along the Matton cow in
most of the division strength was placed
there. The Japanese moved to attack
these positions on October 15th
okay.
With the second division,
with a Japanese second division assigned
to swing forward and live in hit the
marines from the south in an area where
polars men unweighted nine infantry
battalion set out on this March total of
5,600 men excluding artillery and other
support troops. The soldiers
carried or dragged everything,
even guns over the rough trails.
They were late in making their attack
and abandoned many guns on the trail.
So the Japanese are coming in.
They're coming aggressively.
Okay.
A company was weaker by one platoon in
the other companies for despite protests
of Croner polar,
there was an outpost of 46 of its men,
some 3000 yards to their front,
commanded by Sergeant Ralph Briggs
Junar Afford Edwards, Wisconsin.
These men had been out for several
days to warn of an enemy approach.
Colonel Polar was on the field phone
during the day of digging in trying to
persuade his regimental commander to
have headquarters withdraw Briggs and his
patrol. They're going to
sacrifice those men. That's all.
We don't need any bait on the hook. As you
say, if they're coming, they're coming.
This is foolishness to throw away that
platoon and they do a great job in the
mini series,
the Pacific of kind of showing this
and if you ever watch the Pacific,
I mean just watch it, watch it about 10
times. I've probably watched it 20 times
and he tries to keep them as safe as he
can back to the book. All right. He said,
let's get this straight.
Hold your hold.
Fire until you get an order from me that
the outpost must get clear before we
open up.
If the bastards breakthrough,
use the bayonet and keeps
someone at every phone.
Weight Puller looked at his watch.
It was 10 o'clock yells, rolled,
yells, rolled from the right
Japanese voices shouting in English,
blood for the emperor marine,
you die.
A marine bellowed back to hell
with your goddamn emperor.
Sergeant Manila.
John Basel owns nest of guns is about
the center of c company in the middle of
the line with a slight
decline in his front.
The enemy toward him so persistently that
he covered the hill with their bodies
and when the first fury of attack faded,
he sent men to push down the wall of
enemy bodies to clear the fire lane.
Okay?
Of course,
that's John Basil owned who was awarded
the Medal of honor for those actions
that night.
Now there's a a artillery commander,
a little bit to the rear named Deval
and polar is asking devolve for massive
artillery support because they're like
going to be overrun polar called the vol.
Again, give us all you've got.
We're holding on by our toenails.
I'll give you all your call for a polar,
but God knows what will happen
when this ammo we have is gone.
If we don't need it now, we'll never need
it. If they get through here tonight,
there won't be a tomorrow. That's,
that's the situation that they were in.
Reagan fuller called from the
CP from the flank. Colonel,
I'm just about running out of ammo.
I've used almost three and a half
units of fire. You got bayonets,
haven't you fuller? Sure. Yes
sir. All right. Then hang on.
And the heaviest of the firing.
When polar law had left the CP,
regimental headquarters
called for him not here, sir.
The wireman said Colonel Polos Upfront,
find him,
get him on the phone after the crew had
made several calls to the line position,
pull the returned and talked
to the regimental commander.
If you remaining in the pit,
heard Paulo's explosive reply,
what do you mean what's going on?
We're neck,
neck deep in a firefight and I have
no time standing here, both linking.
If you want to find out what's going on,
come up and see.
You know,
he was that good,
like he was that good that
he was able to do that.
You know,
it's kind of like rebel and I was talking
about Steve jobs a couple podcasts ago
and I was like, hey look, he
was a, he was not a good leader.
He was abusive and he was,
but he was so good at these other skills.
Well he pulled her such a great leader
down the chain of command and he's such a
great tactician and he's so brave and
so do dump dominant on the battlefield.
Then he does this stuff and like
basically gets away with it. Yeah.
Back to the book, there was
one enemy, prison prisoner,
a little solid warrant officer who refused
to talk when he was brought to polar.
The colonel was so stunned
by the insolence of the
prisoner that he slapped him
with the flat end of an entrenching tool.
Teeth spilled from the jabs mouth,
but they were false teeth.
He gave no information.
Even then a later prisoner
talk freely with polar
and polar asked him,
why didn't you change your tactics when
you saw you weren't breaking our line?
Why don't you shift to a weaker
spot that is not the Japanese way.
The plan had been made.
No one would have dared to change it.
It must go as it is written.
That's why we have decentralized command.
That's the opposite of
decentralized command. That's
called centralized command.
Here's the plan. This is what you will
execute. Don't do anything different.
Back to the book, and this is kind
of after this thing settled down.
That's why they prisoners.
That's why he's doing interrogation.
That's why he's asking, why
didn't you bring it? You know,
why don't you change your tax? When you
broke the line back to the book pullers,
men found 250 Japanese dead
inside their lines during the day.
About 25 of them. Officers want a
major who had committed suicide,
leaving a final entry in his diary
on the loss of his colors and troops.
Yeah,
I do not know what excuse to give.
I apologize for what I have done.
I'm going to return my borrowed
life today with short interest.
Yeah,
I fought that.
That was worth bringing up because you
always hear about the fanaticism of the
Japanese, but there you go. That's it.
I apologize and I'm going to kill myself
because I didn't succeed in my mission.
Okay.
Polars casualty for the
battle where 19 dead,
30 wounded and 12 missing two or three
days later when the stench of bloated
bodies in his front made his med Rach
polar persuaded division to make count of
the enemy casualties and bury the corpses.
This burial detail counted 1,462 bodies
and spent two days in the grizzly work,
bulldozers, grout, Gow, tolls and
covered the enemy dead and great pits.
So that's incredible.
Incredible that kill ratio.
Hmm.
The colonel washed in the river with
the troops and Reagan fuller notice that
even when he washed his uniforms,
he stripped with the enlisted men in the
river or common touch. The men liked.
Fuller said though a few of the Klaus
where type officers and the rear rank
snickered behind his back.
The men knew he was real,
that he never put on an
act and they loved him.
Okay.
And again, here's the dichotomy of it.
Like we know what a hard ass he is.
Back to the book. Polar Shield is
shielded his men from unnecessary work.
A young officer who insisted that they
police up the battalion area removing jap
beer cans and the debris of the battle
was stopped by by the colonel. Forget it.
Old Man. Let the boys get in their
sacks and leave them the hell alone.
They're half dead from fever and fighting
and they'll have to hop to it again
any day now. So there you go. That's the,
that's like he just nails that perfect.
Another
situation, polar was 300 to 400
yards behind the point of his column.
The first salvo of Japanese fire burst
just in front of him for the first time
and he's a combat career spanning 23
years. His luck ran out under enemy fire.
He was blown from his feet by a spray
of flying metal shell fragments has torn
his legs and lower body
and he was bleeding freely.
The field telephone was
carried by a Marine Justin,
his rear call headquarters old
man Poehler said, I can't sir.
The wire's been cut.
The kernels struggled unsteadily
to his feet and tried to help the
communications man repair the wire as
he stood an enemy sniper shot anatomy
sniper shot him twice through the flesh
of his arm with a small caliber bullets.
He sank back to the ground
sergeant Pennington and
come up by now and he helped
shepherd lift polar into a Poncho and
get them off and get them off the ground
to avoid tetanus infection.
Shepherd bent over polar.
Are you able to stay in command, sir?
Yes, of course I am. I'll be okay.
I can't leave these men.
May I call for artillery fire if I can
get rid of your phone working? Yes.
If you know how men shoveled out a
foxhole for polar and lowered him into the
Poncho.
Okay.
The telephone was placed in the hole with
him and when the line was repaired he
cradled the phone in one arm
and talked with headquarters.
Pennington listened as he discussed a
mortar barrage across the river the next
morning and the launching
of a dawn attack.
These all shot up and blown up and he's
planning an attack for the morning.
Shepherd called in the artillery fire
shall soon burst in the thickets across
the stream and the enemy was quiet
for the rest of that evening.
Late in the night,
pull a realized that he could no longer
walk and called division headquarters.
I find myself unable to
proceed by leading my troops.
He said after it'll delay word
came back major Jonsi Webber,
we'll assume command of your
battalion within a few hours.
He's leaving the perimeter immediately,
so that was, you know, he gets a
pulled out.
Going back to the book,
Lieutenant Colonel Polar is being
recommended by General Vandegrift for the
medal of honor for leading his battalion
with seven holes in him continually for
24 hours.
Okay.
Three got recommended
for the medal of honor.
This did not develop with
the division commander.
In addition to commending polars battalion
for its perimeter defense and putting
in for a third navy crosswords
commander also wrote,
I have known Louis polar since 1919
he was one of the best combat patrol
officers I knew just as he is
an outstanding officer today.
He did a wonderful job with his battalion
on Guadalcanal and every phase of the
operation I have is proud
to have him as a friend,
as I was glad to have him as a marine.
January 1st, 1943 was warm and
sunny and the loading went smoothly.
The gear was all stowed in the
last of the First Marine Division.
Troops were going a board.
It was only then that they're
conditioned became apparent.
Men who had fought for four months in
the Fallis climate and Pacific and had
been shelled, bombed, or shot by snipers,
almost constantly between battles
seem to collapse. At the same moment,
scores were unable to climb the nets
into the ships and had to be carried a
board.
They had shocked expressions with
glazed sunken eyes for weeks.
Most of them would be patients
with malaria, dysentery,
assorted fevers and fungus infections.
Virtually every man in the division
had malaria. By now, polar said,
it isn't so much that they're
sick or even worn out.
It's the reaction from the discovery
that they're finally leaving this damn
place,
and yet a lot of them grew into men here.
Okay?
The divisions dead.
We're 1,242 and 2,655 had been wounded.
Sickness was near total.
Okay?
No one could yet grasped the
importance of the island fighting.
On the day of loading out,
the longest of the Pacific
island campaigns had been
fought and the pattern of
future victories had been set.
The Japanese had paid a higher price
here then they would pay again,
headed thrown all their disposal ships,
planes,
men and machines.
Okay.
More than 50,000 men had been lost on the
island or on the ships trying to reach
it. In Japan, it was already
known as the island of
death.
For more than a year,
Radio Tokyo was to call
the First Marine Division,
the Guadalcanal butchers.
So
that's Guadalcanal.
He actually heads home and here we go.
Back to the book,
an aid in the office in
Washington General Thomas Whole,
Colm jolted in with the news.
The generals given you to the army polar,
I mean on loan for three or four months.
General Marshall wants you to explain the
Guadalcanal fighting to his troops all
over the country.
You need an Fred about leaving your men.
The division will be in Australia for the
next six months before he can get back
into action. I expect you'll rejoin
it in time for another big show.
So there's time between these big island
campaigns and he goes home to America
to take over or spread the word about
what the fighting was like back to the
book.
He often spoke three times daily.
He was on and off planes until he
all but lost track of his route.
He told the story of his fight for the
perimeter of Basil own pushing the wall
of enemy bodies down the hill of
burials by bold bows are in of weapons.
They used, he told of patrols and
thick growth, but never of his wounds.
Okay.
I can't tell you the Japs are no damn
good. He said because they are good,
but we're better.
One American properly trained can
handle two of the yellow bastards.
They have discipline and they use
the jungle cover better than we do,
but they can't think on their own.
I'll say that again.
They have discipline and they use the
jungle cover better wound then we do,
but they can't think on their own.
That's a critical dichotomy
that the discipline,
which obviously obviously
is something that I am
okay
passionate about.
Sure.
But if you put so much discipline
in too much discipline in place,
people don't think for themselves
anymore. Yeah. They just wait. Yeah.
They never change battle plans. Once
they're made, regardless of cost,
they think they'd lose face.
They have no artillery to compare with
ours and our guns chew them to pieces.
They get the jungle rot
just as much as we do.
They're not supermen and we'll with the
hell out of them and you'll be helping
to do it soon, I suppose. If you
take your training seriously,
then there's nothing to worry about,
but you'll have to be hard and you can
be hard when you write with your families
to try to convince them that were in
a war to the finish and then all these
strikes and softness and confusion,
we'll have to go.
Okay.
I can tell you one more thing.
There are worse things than
dying for your country.
Yeah.
When he spoke to the war production
board officials in Washington,
here's what he said.
I want to ask you why American
troops shouldn't have the best,
the world's best fighting equipment on
Guadalcanal. We saw our trenching shovels.
Break it first.
Use all over.
Men now have jap shovels because
they're better and more dependable.
JAP field glasses are better too.
I have good ones myself,
German glasses that I've
carried for 20 years.
Why should American glasses be so poor,
not worth a damn and the tropics,
they fog up and they are improperly
sealed. Once they get damped,
they're done for,
I've seen hundreds of pairs tossed away
in the jungle or c because men know they
can see as well with the naked eye.
What kind of American ingenuity
or patriotism produced those
he doesn't play.
This is the little part about humility.
We'll have to get over the idea that we're
the greatest people on earth in every
respect, that we're infallible and that
no one else has ideas worth considering.
One of the reasons we had to fight against
the odds on Gratta Canal Guadalcanal
was this insufferable American notion
of superiority and our carelessness and
the face of danger. It goes back to
Pearl Harbor and far beyond. He's saying,
you've got to stay humble.
You can't be arrogant.
Yeah.
He was summoned before the high command
of the Marine Corps and gave some gay
and gave the same forthright
picture of the fighting he had seen.
Gentlemen,
we have some of the same old troubles,
staff officers who've
never seen combat issue,
unrealistic orders that cost
lives, time, money and ruin morale.
For example,
we were out there on that island try and
trying to defend a perimeter when they
waited, when they wanted to send
a patrol outside the command.
Never used a single regimen but
sent out three mixed battalions.
The logical thing would have been a
regular regimen with one battalion leading
the other and the other two
covering officers and men
will be familiar with each
other and there would never be
questioned about who is in command,
but when we did go out, it was
almost always with mixed battalions.
It may look good in the staff
officers chart here at headquarters,
but it didn't work.
Brought us only stumbling and confusing
and casualties more than once.
When we were out in the jungle,
nobody really knew who was in command.
I could cite you the names of many
of man I lost because of that.
It was inexcusable.
This is something that it absolutely is,
is very important to understand,
especially for guys that aren't,
well I guess anybody, you, you work
in your train in a certain way,
as much as you can stay in the groups
that you work in, train with. Right.
And for them to just randomly,
and who knows why they did this.
But I'll tell you what I've seen.
I've seen this where let's
say there's some operation,
uh, that's a high visibility
operation that everyone thinks, wow,
that'd be a cool operation to
do. Well, instead of just taking,
let's say one company, they go, okay,
well we want to get multiple different
people to get to be able to be involved
in this operation.
So we'll take one platoon for this
company and one platoon from this other
company at one platoon for this other
company and we'll just send them all out
there. That's exactly what he's
talking about. It's like, no, no. Hey,
sorry, you guys aren't going
to go on this operation.
We're sending Alpha Company or
Bravo company or whatever. Right.
That's the way you do
it. Yeah. Play around.
Here's a little comment because
I love the machine guns.
Little comment on the
art of machine gunnery.
These guns are the most
important firepower to infantry.
Just,
I'm just making that statement.
Tested Code Chesty Puller statement g
machine guns.
Go be a machine gunner.
You know what I'm saying?
I ain't know what to say.
I was so fired up one day we're at the
gym and I walked in, there was some,
some kid was signing up and he was not,
I call him a kid.
He was probably old man. 24 years old.
Yeah. And so I said, hey, old man. No.
And you know, I think,
uh, I said, you know,
I could tell you had like a
high and tight. I was like, oh,
are you in the military? He goes, yeah,
I'm in the Marine Corps. I said, well,
what are you doing? The Marine Corps?
He said, machine gunner dig it. S
awesome.
All right.
Here's another, another
comment. We just don't know.
All we ought to know about warfare
on land or sea. Just off Guadalcanal.
Not long ago,
we lost three cruises.
Cruisers blasted down by Jap guns as
they sat there sitting ducks. That's all.
I'll tell you exactly why we lost him.
The admiral in charge got a plain report
that the JAP force was approaching at
14 knots by daylight,
so we figured at this speed the enemy
couldn't arrive in his waters before the
next dawn. After dark. Of course,
the jab stepped up their speed
to 28 knots and got there,
got to the scene at 3:00 AM when our
men were not even at battle stations.
Instead of keeping it happened like that,
I'm positive and instead of
keeping such thing secret,
we ought to have them emblazoned
on the gate at every naval station.
We must not be too proud or too stupid
to profit by our mistakes and God knows
that we make them. Have you ever heard
the term profit from our mistakes before?
No, but I really like it. Yeah,
I think I really like it too.
Why not profit from your
mistakes? It's brilliant. Yeah.
Yeah. It kind of puts it
more into prison, you know,
they say learn from your mistakes. Right?
Yeah. Cool. But when you say products,
so much more valuable.
Yeah. Talks a little bit about, uh,
well,
the psychological impact of combat.
I know something about the strain of
combat. For five years in Nicaragua,
I marched at least 20 days a month
under constant threat of enemy ambushed,
but it never saw those.
But I never saw on those Indian troops
any sign of battle fatigue or anything
resembling it in the Pacific.
I saw a lot of our people break down.
My reaction is this,
what does it matter how you're
killed if you're killed in battle,
why does the louder noise in a fight with
heavy artillery and bombs makes such a
difference?
I think the difference is entirely in
the mind and the preparation of men for
combat in Haiti actions. When I fought,
the men were all picked volunteers.
Professionals who are paid to fight and
realize they might die in the trade.
I'm sure from my own experience that it's
the mental attitude I went through the
worst days they had on Guadalcanal and I
didn't suffer a bit. I lost some weight.
But that was because we
didn't get the proper food.
If we make our men tof in the mind before
they go to war and give them an honest
idea of what war is like,
we won't have so much of this trouble.
Why do we have to baby them with all this
crap about careers and opportunity and
foreign travel. Ah, yeah.
You know what I mean?
You know what I mean? Yeah. That
makes a lot of sense there. You know,
they say, I forget where I read
this, but people who come back from,
from war, they, they kind of
differentiated like were people who were,
who were in it like,
you know how like JP and you and,
and I just always wanted to do this to
be a combat leader, to be a navy seal,
to be a commando. You know, like typically
people with that kind of attitude,
they don't get affected by it because
it's kind of like the thing where it
affected less. Yeah. Generally you are
correct generally guys that
like special operations guys that
that's what they wanted to do. Yeah.
There's a whole bunch of other things
that play into that as well. The training,
because he's talking about hard training.
Well guess what? In special operations,
you do get harder training, you
have a tighter, uh, or you have,
you have a real close relationship with
all your guys and you stay together with
your guys. That is helpful too. I mean,
it's not any type of relationship
that you have and an infantry platoon,
trust me,
I've seen those in Marine Corps and army
of trend and military units get tight.
It doesn't matter whether you're special
operations or not. Uh, but the training,
they step up the training, they make
it really hard. That plays a role.
But I think you're right is that guys
that think that that's what they want to
do, then that helps as well. So
there's a bunch of little factors,
but I think what his point is like
there's two, there's two points.
Number one, make the training hardest. I
guess there's three points. Number one,
make the training hard as hell.
Number two,
make sure people know what to expect
and don't talk to them about like the
career opportunities.
I just answered this question on the way
of the warrior kid podcast, right? Well,
I answered the question. The question
was, is it fun to be a navy seal?
And I answered the question,
Hey, is it fun? Yes,
absolutely. It's fun. That's part of it.
But the other part of it is you are
going to go to war and you could die and
that's a harsh thing to tell a
nine year old or a 10 year old,
but that's exactly what you should
tell a nine year old and a 10 year old
because that's what you're signing up for.
I was,
I was doing another interview recently
and I told this story and I've,
I've told it before,
but you know,
it was like the first time some woman
that I had been working with a company and
some woman that was her
husband or something. Anyways,
the woman said, you know, can you meet my
son? He really wants to be a navy seal,
you know, and I was, you know, I said,
Oh yeah, sure. You know, who the kid was,
whatever, 17 or 18 years
old. He was a junior,
senior in high school and he was
this, you know, strapping kid who is,
you know, look like a great athlete. And
she wanted to bring me to lunch with him.
So we went to lunch and, and it was,
you know, the details of the story.
I don't recall exactly, but it was
basically, uh, you know, my son,
he wants to be a navy seal.
He,
he's on the swim team and he's on the
track team and he played football and he
just loves working out and he just, I
think he'd be great. And then he just,
he can do 28 pull ups and the kid's like,
yeah, I love working out and across.
I surf too. And I love the ocean. I love
the water. And it was like cool. And,
and you know, for awhile, you know,
I was listening and then, you know,
of course I was like, yeah, you
know, that's, that sounds like,
it sounds like you'd be well prepared
for the physical aspects of it,
but what you have to remember is
that the reason you become a seal,
so you can go and fight in wars and you're
going to kill people and you're gonna
be at the risk of dying and you're
going to be at the risk of being,
and that's what's going
to happen to your friends,
if not you and the,
when I got done saying like
on that sentence, the mom's
face completely changed.
Yeah. Because it's what he's talking
about right here, which is, hey, you know,
it's travel and adventure and career
opportunities. Like know what it is, is,
is war and savagery and the worst
things that you could possibly experience
is what you're gonna experience.
That's what you need to
tell people. Yeah. Yeah.
The special operations and the conclusion
for what what I was reading there was
people when they go in knowing
and kind of how they put it,
like forward leaning into,
uh,
the realities of a military situation.
Yeah.
It tends to be special operations or
guys who want to do it for that reason.
Not The guy who got sold on world travel.
[inaudible] guy's definitely going
to have a rougher time with it.
And you've got to remember too,
there's hundreds of,
there's a massive percentage
of army, infantry, marine
corps, infantry. Guess what?
They want to be marine corps,
infantry. They want to be,
that's what they want to do.
That they're just as passionate about that
as some guy that like, cause that job,
it's a little bit different, but a lot
of that parts of that job are, you know,
when we had Brian Stann on, we talked
about this, you know, like Brian Stan was,
you get to be in charge of more
people. You get, it's, it's a,
it's a different dynamic.
But the combat leadership opportunities
in and just the combat opportunities.
I mean, when we were in Ramadi, yeah.
Like I had the infantry in Ramadi,
those guys were freaking getting after it.
They were just,
it was insane to watch those
guys. So, yeah, I, you know,
there's plenty,
I mean,
there's the vast majority or
there's plenty of guys in the,
in the regular conventional
forces, they don't, they,
they do just as good after combat as the,
as the special operations guys do.
So it's more, and you know, we
talked about this Peter a Tia,
it was like if a guy's fractured going in,
it doesn't matter if it's
special operations or
conventional forces or general
purpose units, he's, if he's fractured
going in, the war's gonna mess him up.
If he's solid going in, he's
going to do well. Right.
So that's the determining factor.
The training definitely helps the telling
people the truth up front definitely
helps, but you don't know what
you're going to get. Yeah.
And there's also plenty of guys as
special operations that do have serious
issues. Yeah. Yeah. And the article
wasn't about like special operations,
so that's not what it was about.
It was more about the state of mind.
I think special where I know that special
operations was just like an example of
some of some point that they're
making. Well we talked, again,
I'm referencing all these different
podcasts, but when Jordan Peterson was on,
we talked about like the
offensive mindset, right?
And the morning offensive you can be
generally the more psychologically
comforting that is,
it's,
it's psychologically uncomfortable
to be on the defensive.
It's psychologically more comfortable
to be on the offensive right there.
I just get the right,
yes. Cycle. Okay. Yeah.
Psychologically uncomfortable
to be on the defensive.
Psychologically more comfortable.
It's not necessarily comfortable cause
you still have bad things that can happen
when you're on offense,
but it's definitely
psychologically more comfortable.
So those things play a role.
You happen like to your experience
or are you considered an experience?
It's like I'm going to happen to this
experience rather than this is going to be
offensive instead of
defensive. Absolutely. Kind
of like when people say, hey,
how life's, how's life treating you
versus how are you treating life?
You know that old saying. Yeah. You
see what I'm saying? I'll go with it.
Just go with it. Let's go ahead. Here's,
here's another thing that he did.
He calls out and this is very interesting
and everyone that's in the military
will hear this and kind
of shake their head.
The practice of having command
post exercises. Polar said though,
he realized that he was treading
on prominent toes in his audience.
We take skeleton forces of headquarters
troops and the like just a handful and
go through exercises so
often that we forget.
We aren't simulating that we
aren't simulating actual warfare.
It has become so bad that even platoons
are carrying out command post exercises
in battle. Of course, once you set
up a CP, which is a command post,
you stop for all.
You stop all forward motion because
the commanders sit on their duffs in
relative security and when
you hope forward motion,
you get in trouble immediately. I
have to admit, we have to learn.
I admit we have to learn
how to handle commands,
but we've carried it to
a ridiculous extreme.
They do a lot of that command exercises.
W the,
the most unrealistic thing about it is
like he's saying that you'll have not a
real platoon but like a
small representation of a
platoon so the commander can
move that platoon around real easily.
Cause it's this little thing.
But then when you have a real platoon
that takes real vehicles in real,
you know,
it's like moving pieces on a board as
opposed to like when you move this,
this battalion from here to there, it
all you do is just move this move there,
move there, piece on a board.
That was real easy. Yeah.
You look at what actually happens in
the field when you move that piece of
looking battalion and it's massive.
It's Ha,
it's this incredible
project to make it happen.
Yeah. To move a battalion, you know,
four miles or two miles or whatever.
It's like,
well this is what it's going to take.
Fuel and food and ammunition and
wounded and planning all this stuff.
But the person up top just cause oh yeah,
we'll just make that Italian leather.
One morning as he approached the company
of his men, lounging among their tents,
a newly arrived lieutenant barked an
order and the marine scrambled to their
feet standing at attention. What the
Hell's wrong with you? Pull a roared.
Don't you think I've got more sense
than demand that you put on a show?
Every time I come within pistol range,
get back down on your ducts.
You ought to know me well enough
that I'm no bandbox soldier.
Take it easy. There's enough for you to
do when we get to our next assignment.
Again, dichotomy is that okay? You
don't need to snap to attention.
Every time I come around,
there's an army quartermaster and the
general showed up and they had asked for a
bunch of shotgun shells.
Here we go. Back to the book.
He's asked for 10,000
brass buck shot shells.
What the devil it is you want with
those to kill jabs with sir. It doesn't.
Colonel Polar know that buck shot is
prohibited by the Geneva Convention.
Sir Colonel Polar doesn't give a damn
about the Geneva convention any more than
the Japs did at Pearl Harbor.
Okay?
Now as they're getting
ready to go and assault, um,
Gloucester,
the enemy had word of
the coming assault radio,
Tokyo blared one afternoon
in late December,
the first American Marine Division
assorted cutthroats degenerates and jail
birds has been chased out of Melbourne,
is now in camp in New Guinea and
we'll try to invade Cape Gloucester.
I'm pleased to add that our soldiers
are fully prepared to repulse the,
since little attempt the jungles,
we'll run red with the blood of the
Guadalcanal butchers. So that's, that's,
that's the propaganda cut throats
degenerates in jail birds.
So now they're going to Gloucester,
Cape Gloucester.
On the early morning of December 26th,
they stood off Cape Gloucester.
Big Guns on the fleet rolled for
a half for an hour and a half,
beginning before dawn or the marines
and their traditional d day, Bruh eight,
their traditional DDA breakfast of
steak and eggs while solve those,
shook the halls beneath them.
Third Battalion Seventh Marines landed
first quickly followed by polars old
battalion,
which floundered through a morass behind
of the beach and pushed up the tall
knoll already known to aviators
and ship gunners as target hill.
An hour after the seventh was a shore,
the first marines came turn toward the
airfield and walked into a well laid
Japanese Sam Bush tanks.
Big tanks came into clear
the enemy from there,
hidden bunkers and by nightfall the first
was well on its way to the airfield,
a falling tree in a soggy forest,
injured one marine and otherwise there
were only 20 killed and 22 wounded on d
day.
Enemies.
Casualties were estimated
at 50 on December 30th the
first and fifth secured the
field after hand to hand fighting in
which they had to call on tanks for help.
Okay.
Once sergeant remembered a moment
from a mortar attack by the enemy,
a kid sitting there and his foxhole,
he didn't have any head,
he just had a neck with dog tags on it.
A great face.
Youngster nearby was muttering as he fled,
as he fired his rifle,
it don't do any good. I got three
of them, but it don't do any good.
Japanese snipers had infiltrated the line
and killed marines at short range and
one unit tried wade.
The stream was broken.
It's survivors driven to hide in the
weeds on the edge from midstream.
A boy who failed to make it over,
hung over a log his body riddled by a
score of bullets for and a half an hour or
more. He called to his mates before
he died, I'm here. Here I am.
The attack had stalled the line and now
become u shaped with a pocket of the
enemy holding back the
center General Rupert,
us from division relieved the commander
of the third battalion, seventh marines,
and sent polar into action once more with
orders to reorganize and drive forward
the unit.
So
they weren't making any progress and
the commander said, you know what,
I'm putting polar beckon action.
Send the wolf.
The trouble was the same and here's,
here's puller.
Talking to his guys as he showed up,
the pillow was the same old thing.
The trouble was the same old thing.
Staff officers don't know the meaning
of terrain and how it can slowed down
troops and costs lives. I went up to
the front about two in the afternoon.
I called the company commanders and told
them as briefly as I could what I had
in mind. I've been sent to take over.
Your commander has been relieved.
I don't intend to believe,
be relieved.
You can bet on that we're going
to attack here in the morning.
There were protests that the jap bunkers
could not be seen and that they were
cutting up our line.
I told them I had the medicine for that.
I ordered up some of Joe Buckley's half
tracks because I knew their guns could
deal with the bunkers.
The resistance was fairly light,
but the staff orders were so foolish
that we were just sitting targets that
we're making sitting
targets of our people.
Buckley did a great job
there as he always did.
They had orders in these battalions to
guide both right and left and order.
That can't be followed well,
even on a per ne parade ground.
Any beginner knows that you can
guide left or you can guide,
right or even center, but you can't
follow two leaders on either side.
At the same time.
The line will buckle and cause gaps.
We were frustrating the troops
with delays to reform the line.
I just said, now we will go forward and
forget about all this guiding business.
Just forget there's anybody on the flanks.
We have enough power here to
drive and we're going to drive,
blow your way through.
Think of nothing else.
Okay,
so important part there.
Once again,
you can't follow multiple
leaders at the same time.
And he's talking about a physical example
like guiding in the military is when
you're marching, you look to
your left and you, you, you fall,
you line up with the person to your left.
And usually these people were saying,
no lineup with a person to your
left and the person to your right.
How the hell are you going to do
that? You'd not, that's the answer.
Before the gun stopped. A staff
officer from division, uh,
and and
okay.
A staff officer from division went
up on the line and here he says,
I went up there and the heaviest of the
action when fire was flying all around
us, polar walked around outside the wire
and hills six 60 and stopped at every,
dug out to talk to some kid. He'd say,
how's things going in their old man,
just as if he'd come from next
door to borrow a cup of sugar.
Those kids thought it was the
greatest thing that ever happened.
You'd think you'd been
handing out thousand dollar
bills down the line and there
was some place to spend them.
Polaroid found one d moralized boy sitting
stone lean his whole looking out with
a telltale thousand yard stare. He
murdered over and over. Colonel,
we gotta get the Hell Outta here.
That's no way to talk. Old Man.
Polar led the boy a few paces to the rear
and sat with him for 10 minutes or so.
Look old, man. I want to go home too.
I'm not getting any younger. Hell,
I'm 45 years old.
You know that I've got a family at home.
I know this dump is no good,
but neither of us is going home until we
lick these bastards. We've got to make,
we've got to help make our
folks at home safe too.
I'll try and get you some hot
chow up here. Old Man. So again,
you just got a guy that's totally gets it.
Yeah,
lots of heavy fighting a, they get
Gloucester secured. In February,
1944 polar had a physical examination
and the Cape and the camp at Cape
Gloucester and aside from a notation of
a recent attack of malaria was found in
perfect condition.
On the same day upon hearing rumor that
one third of the veterans of Guadalcanal
was to be rotated back to the states.
Paul wrote general whole comb the
commandant in terms which would have been
appreciated by a Caesar or Napoleon.
It is respectfully requested that my
present assignment to a combat unit be
extended until the downfall
of the Japanese empire
freaking get some.
Okay.
The division recouped
and drew replacements.
The first of the new weapons began to
appear in quantities. The Springfields.
It almost disappeared
now to pull her sorrow.
He was interested in the first
of a new style flame thrower.
When an officer brought
one by the youngster,
proudly explained the work of the deadly
torch and look to polar for approval.
Where's the bayonet fit on it?
It's another like famous quote from
Chesty Puller. Here's a flame thrower,
but you need to put a bayonet
fitting on it. Just in case
he's counseling is officers about
about showing being brave and
stepping up and at the same time,
here's the, here's the dichotomy. He says,
I don't want you to go up
under the guns just for show.
It's only the idiots in green kids
who think they're bulletproof,
but if you don't show some courage,
your officers won't show it either and
the kids will hang back. It's that.
It's that kind of an outfit
that always has trouble.
Next we go pull a return to Porvoo
to find a new stern. The camps,
the allied landings in France,
we're expanding.
The new [inaudible] had begun to bomb
Tokyo [inaudible] panted fallen whole
fleets of cargo ships had brought the
first division new equipment to pursue,
and there was word of an independent
role for the marines in a new operation.
General Macarthur would follow his
own southern course on island hopping,
but the core would stab
into central Pacific.
Polar could hardly conceive the
scope of the new Marine Corps,
which he had known to as a force of Amir.
19,000 is prewar days.
There are now five divisions in and
to brigade in the Pacific and another
division in training in California.
Well over 100,000 men.
Okay.
In late July,
on that same day,
Franklin Roosevelt and Harry Truman were
nominated for the coming elections back
home.
Marines landed on Guam.
Okay.
A few days after Lewis got the news,
Lieutenant Colonel Sam
Polar had been killed.
Shot through the heart by
a machine gunners. Bullet.
Yeah.
Is intimates. Notice a new reserve
in the kernel and these days,
but it was not long before still another
false report which added to the growing
puller legend Marines whispered that
when he got word of Sam's death,
he had said grimly, those who live
by the sword must die by the sword.
Okay.
The loss of Sam had in
fact touched Lewis' deeply.
He covered it with silence and to hurry
turning to other topics when officers
spoke of his brother's death.
Okay.
On [inaudible],
the division intensified it's work and
sweat it at war games on the beaches and
in the palm groves there was a new
watchword Pellalou the next target.
So Yup.
His brother,
Lieutenant Colonel Sam Polar was
killed and he got word of that.
Yeah,
hundred only a hundred thousand marines.
That might seem like a lot, but that's,
that's not a lot when you consider what
the tasks that they had before them.
Okay,
so now they're heading, they're
heading to Pella Lu. The next target,
when the big fleet left for the plows to
follow the bombardment ships there was
bought a single somber note aboard.
One of the vessels were stacks of many
hundreds of white wooden crosses far more
than a two days' supply.
Two days from Pellalou.
There was a report from the underwater
demolition teams who's met at boldly
swimming to shore and inspected
jap defenses. Nothing serious.
They said the way would be cleared.
Polars mind was not relieved.
He had never before felt pessimism
at the opening of a battle.
Now we're starting the invasion.
There was no moon.
The Sky was filled with stars and
there was not a trace of cloud.
Toward The dawn of September 15th the
transports had come into position on the
horizon, the guns, it's the
guns of the fleet. Spurted fire.
For hours the funder was unbroken,
but as gray edge sky as grads,
the sky pace slowed and
the fire became to sultry.
The island was invisible.
Occasional flares erupted above it in
the darkness and drifted from site.
The troops had breakfast before daylight,
steak and eggs again,
and when the first of
them came to the decks,
the chain of the Palau's lay in a
black silhouette across the sea.
There was a moderate swell,
a breeze spraying up coming
from the island of Pella,
Lou.
Okay.
The guns broken to a full cry once more
and the final shelling struck target.
The two assault battalions of the
first marines went aboard board.
The big landing vehicles on the decks.
The malls of the ship's clanked open
in the amphibious tractors were spewed
forth milling as they formed lines
ready to move forward toward the breach.
The beach,
they were 4,000 yards out.
Vast flights of planes came over
wheeling in from all directions.
They dived,
bombed and climbed over pell Lou for an
hour or more and soon after the first of
the bombs fell, a slow hesitant
curtain gathered over the land.
It seemed impossible that anything
living could have endured,
but Alaska is the assault began a puff
of anti aircraft smoke flowered in the
sky and a plane dropped in flames just
before eight 30 the first wave started
short polar watch for the signal flag to
dip from the yard arm of a control boat
in his front.
The amtraks foamed away on the broad
wakes at almost eight 30 precisely the
vehicle ground on the sand.
Polar never forgot the scene.
I went up over the side as fast as I
could scramble and ran my cal at least 25
yards before I hit the beach flat down.
When I looked back to the Amtrak,
I saw four or five shells hit it
all at once. A few men were killed,
getting out too slow,
but most of them were saved because
they got out before we stopped moving.
We lost our communications officer.
His leg was blown off
and he couldn't be saved.
I look down the beach and saw a mess.
Every damn damn tracking.
Our wave had been destroyed in the
water by the enemy or shot to pieces.
The minute it landed, I tried to
get aligned, set up for defense.
The wireman were there fast.
As soon as I was doing their
job without further orders,
and we lost several of
them in the hot fire,
every platoon leader was trying to
form a line of his own. Just as I was,
runners were going up
and down the beaches.
We tried to get organized that big PR
promitory on my left hadn't been touched
by all the ship's guns and planes and we
got a whirlwind of machine gun and anti
tank fire pullers.
Second Battalion drove through a heavy
growth of woods now torn by the shelling
and by nine 30 had driven 350 yards
ahead to the edge of the airfield.
They tied on the line of the
fifth marines. Casualties
were reported as heavy,
but the trial of the
second had only begun.
The new position was faced by an obstacle
marked on none of the invasion maps,
a sheer coral ridge who
sides were honeycombed with
Japanese positions from Fox
holes to gigantic dug outs of
reinforced steel and concrete.
Some of them with four levels, each of
which could be closed off with steel doors
for eight hours.
The regimen endured the most
savage fighting of the Pacific war.
General Smith had come
across assured 11:30 AM
when the phone line was spicy,
spliced late in the afternoon and he
talked with polar. He had only one.
He had only a calm report
were dug in solid and we've
got the old one phase line.
All right.
Polar night made no mention of especially
heavy casualties or have need for help.
It was estimated that the first marines
had lost 500 men during the day.
The first water that had come
ashore, oil drums, and was foul.
Polar shouted his rage to the officers
on the ships bellowing for new supplies.
Okay,
here's,
here's polars report enemy
well dug in opposition,
strong little damage done by our
preliminary fire. Hard fight ahead,
casualties over 20% I've ordered no man
to be evacuated and less from bullet or
shell wounds.
Request further supply.
Fresh water are still on drinkable men.
Retching
polar called division and talked with
Colonel Seldon, the chief of staff.
He remembered the year, the
conversation years later, Johnny,
half my regimen has gone.
I've got to have replacements.
If I'm to carry out division
orders tomorrow morning,
you know we have no replacements.
Louie,
I told you before we came ashore that
we should have at least one regiment
reserve. We're not fighting a third.
We're not fighting a third of the men.
We brought in all these damn
specialists you brought.
Okay.
Anything wrong with your orders,
Louie? No, I'm ready to go ahead,
but you know my casualties or
50% what do you want me to do?
Get me some of those 17,000 men
on the beach. You can't have them.
They're not trained in for infantry.
Give them to me and by nightfall
tomorrow they'll be trained.
Infantry polar went out with a runner
through the night to find posts of his
battalion commanders
and pass on the order.
We press a top attack at eight o'clock
in the morning. No change. Full speed.
Use every man.
Okay.
He fought,
fell more than once and cut himself on
the coral shepherd and others had left
and others left at headquarters.
Notice that the colonel was beginning to
limp and that his left leg had swollen.
Seldon called back. Pulled in.
You got my orders. Okay. Yes,
you need and explain further.
I just came back from my battalions.
We're going to take of ground
tomorrow without replacements.
We're willing to try,
but don't forget,
we're just going to add 10
or 15% to our casualties.
Yeah.
When the sun rose on September 18th 200
of the 473 men in polars third battalion
were headquarters personnel.
Many frontline units had been
decimated long before noon.
There were cases of heat prostration.
The blazing sun was hotter than ever.
Faces and lips were clack cracked and
bleeding. Salt pills became scarce again.
Polar was optimistic for they
started the attack from high ground,
but the crucial days still lay ahead.
Okay.
Hank Adams came bipolars command post
and found him half clad and filthy sweat
soaked trousers with a
heavy beard on his face.
Okay,
I'm coming back this afternoon.
Colonel,
do you want me to bring you a
a fresh uniform? Hell, Hank,
I've got no time for that. Every man in
the outfit will get clean before I do.
Okay.
Re tenant,
Colonel Lou Walt.
Now the executive officer of the fifth
marines saw polar a command conference
during the day.
Okay.
He was absolutely sick
over the loss of his bed.
Vietnam,
he fought hand to hand until day light,
beating off charges that
no survivor could count.
Yeah.
As firstlight spilled over the ridge,
the shrunken company beat back the
last Japanese attack with stones,
ammunition boxes, bare
fists, and bayonets.
Okay.
Several of the enemy were flung bodily
off the cliff and fell shrieking in onto
the splintered coral below,
but they did it
at the end of the day.
The regiment reported a total
of 1,878 men lost since d day.
The fighting went on without a break until
September 23rd when the first marines
rested in lines without advancing.
They beat off several counterattacks
and patrols pushed out a thousand yards
down the west coast
without serious opposition.
The regimen was relieved
at 2:00 PM of this day.
By the 321st of the 81st army division,
the new commander took one look
at the forward command post.
Polar had occupied and ordered it moved
more than a thousand yards to the rear.
Yeah.
The nine days on the line polars regimen
had eliminated one major block house
and 144 defended caves and lesser
pillboxes division reported that 3,942
Japanese had been killed in the regimens
zone. No enemy had been captured.
Polars total casualty of men were 56%
the highest regimental losses in the
history of the core.
Yeah.
First Battalion had lost 71% the second
56% the third 55% headquarters and
weapons companies,
32%
okay.
General Smith who walked the terrain
after it was finally captured,
said it seemed impossible that men
could have moved forward against the
intricate and mutually supporting
defenses the Japanese had been had set up.
It can only be explained as a reflection
of the determination and aggressive
leadership of colonel polar.
Yeah.
Now,
okay,
polar. That's the last major combat
for polar, was it Pella? Lou,
he ends up going back to the states for
a bit and while he's back on the states
back in the states.
Okay.
America drops the atomic bombs
on Hiroshima and Nagasaki
and the war is over and
shortly thereafter
they order general puller.
Okay.
Two or colonel polar at this time too.
The reserves now.
Okay.
Like I said, he, he, he, he
didn't get along with some people,
especially up the chain of command and
he didn't want to be sent to the reserves
because that's,
that's not what a career marine
wants to do. So here we go.
Back to the book curdle you've been
ordered to reserve duty in New Orleans.
It's a big district, you know,
and very important to the core.
Yeah.
Polar was not misled.
He realized what it meant to be shown
to reserve duty into a side pocket.
Many marine career had ended that way.
One of the inevitable problems with the
marine corps, and this is polar talking,
one of the inevitable problems with
the marine corps or any other military
service is that staff officers take
over the minute a war ended combat.
People run things when the chips are
down and the country's life is at stake.
But when the gun stop,
nobody's got used for combat man.
Okay.
The staff officers are like rats.
They stream out of hiding and takeover.
It's true. Just watch what happens
to paperwork, God and peace time.
They'll put out enough to sink a small
size nation into the sea and when the war
breaks out, most of it just naturally
stops. That's the way they do everything.
There must be a staff
of people of course are,
we'd never get everything done but if
we don't stop this empire building of
staff, somebody's going to come
along and lick us one of these days.
We'll be so nodded and red
tape that we can't move.
Well we, you ever seen that
seal team thing?
Um, I'll put it on a tee shirt or
something but it's a Freddy the frog,
the little symbol of the frog man,
the Freddy the frog and he's like in a
glass jar or a glass casing and it says
in case of war break glass cause like
you don't want the guy around when peace
time is going on. Right, right,
right. That's what, that's what chest,
that's another chesty puller.
Right.
They want them during peacetime
cause he's causes. He speaks up
well.
Piece didn't last that long.
On June 25th,
1950 North Korean troops poured across
the 38th parallel and strength and
warhead returned.
Polar recognized all the signs.
He immediately asked for a modification
of his orders and said urgently to
headquarters.
Attention is invited to the fact that
I served as an officer in Haiti and
Nicaragua and in the Pacific Theater
for eight years prior to the Japanese
attack on Pearl Harbor.
This experience will prove a value in
an assignment to combat duty in Korea
and
well the senior personnel know that.
Then he gets what he asked for.
Polar arrived in southern California
in the heat of late July and found San
Diego and area of bedlam,
marine reservists thronged in it,
ev in from every corner of the nation's
thousands of vehicles towards since
World War Two were being overhauled
and driven to port trains,
bar regulars from the east coast.
Unattached officers came from everywhere
without a call. Volunteers for war.
The First Marine Division was
being created almost from scratch,
so they had,
they had
dismantled so much of the service after
World War II and now they've got to
rebuild it all very quick. They
do. They talk about it in the book.
I skip over that, but we know what
that consists of. Hardcore training,
getting people ready for war.
Finally they get,
he gets to Japan and they're
waiting now to go and Korea
into Korea.
Polar hail,
the passing medical corpsman and
went to a nearby army hospital.
I want to talk with
some of the casualties.
I've got to find out
what's happening in Korea.
He went up in an elevator with an army
doctor who seemed on point on the point
of tears,
go into the wards and see those kids and
you'll soon know more about more than
you want about Korea.
Take a look at all the self inflicted
wounds we've got and those kids are so
green, they don't even realize how
obvious it is. Just from the powder burns.
Polar walked down many rows
of beds talking with the men.
Many of them frightened and broken
and heard their tales of Korea.
Polar was sobered but not despair.
He told some young,
younger officers that night,
there's nothing wrong with American kids.
Their leadership has
just all gone to hell.
There's a whole hospital full of babies.
You might say,
okay.
They were never given a
chance to grow into men.
It won't be that way with our marines,
I'll tell you that
it or preparing for d day in Incheon does
the one biggest amphibious operations
and they're getting ready for that and
he has a little chat with his officers.
We're the most fortunate of men.
Most Times professional soldiers have
to wait 25 years or more for a war,
but here we are with only five years.
Wait for this one.
During that time we've sat on
our fat Duff's drawing our pay.
Now we're getting a chance to earn it
to show the taxpayers were worth it.
We're going to work at our
trade for a little while.
We live by the sword and if necessary,
we'll be ready to die by the sword.
Good luck.
I'll see you a shore
and listen up old man. When you have
something to say to your officers are men,
make it snappy. The fewer words,
the better. They won't believe it.
If you shoot bull
when you face ranks of men and try
that, you can hear him sighing, despair.
When you open your mouth,
if they sense you're a phony,
okay?
They can usually look at you and tell.
Maybe it doesn't sound like it,
but it's an important thing.
You know, marines career.
Don't try and don't try and what
does he call it? Shoot Ball.
Don't try and shoot ball.
Tell the boys what's going on for real.
They see right through you
wrote his wife a letter before he leaves.
Sweet.
I will be unable to write you again
for a few days, but you, Virginia,
Virginia, Mac, Martha, Lee,
and Louis, those are his kids.
Okay?
We'll be constantly in my thoughts.
Yeah.
May God bless you always
and provide for you,
giving you much happiness
and useful lives.
You my children must take advantage of
all opportunities and develop into good
Christians. Much love to all
of you. I love you, Virginia.
I always have.
Okay.
And I always will.
Yeah.
Here we go into in.
Okay.
By five 30 in the afternoon when the first
waves, the marines reached the shore,
the men of the fleet could no longer see
in John hundreds of boats milled in the
outer harbor in their turn crossing the
embarkation line and moving toward land
where they disappeared into
a bank of smoke and dust.
Polar went into his objective at blue
beach with the third wave in a twilight
Hasson hastened by smoke,
Paul and climbed a 15 foot seawall and
one of the scaling ladders improvised on
a ship in route.
They
meet some fairly light resistance.
Here's what polar says,
it won't amount to much. Tonight.
We took them by surprise.
Polars casualties had been light and the
divisions total for the day was only 20
killed in 170 wounded puller was
awake at 3:30 AM calling the battalion
commander and making plans
for an attack at dawn
polar swift drive. Hurry to hurry to
joining forces in an effort to keep pace.
Captain Ray styles of
ridges battalion saw that.
Okay.
The secret was not only
in polars incisive orders,
he gave us pride in some way.
I can't describe all those of us had
heard hundreds of stories about him and
today that we couldn't actually
see him doing great things.
He kept building up our morale higher
and higher just by being there.
Yeah.
When we were moving up to companies
from the adjoining battalions,
marched abreast and got a little mixed.
One of the kid yelled,
one of the kids yelled, what? What
outfit are you with? Mac Fifth Marines.
How about you?
I got a better,
I'm in polars the troops in the first
thought of the old man before they fall
out of their regimental number.
Okay.
By September 17th d day plus two general
MacArthur was impatient to go ashore
from the command ship Mount Mckinley.
He saw that his blow to Korea cut it
into and had taken the enemy by surprise
and the chances of ending the war.
We're good.
Okay.
He radioed Vice Admiral Arthur d Struble,
the task force commander after
the first good news from shore,
the navy and Marines have never shown
more brightly than this morning.
Macarthur
on one of the fiery days of the drive
towards solar. Popular Chaplain,
Father Keating captured five North
Korean soldiers and herded them along is
prisoners.
He hailed a passing marine jeep
driven by private wolf sawn.
Take these prisoners off my hands and
get them to the rear before they're hurt.
I can't father. I'm running ammo into
the edge of town and they're getting low.
I can't stop to do it private.
That's an order.
Okay.
Take them over.
Wolf looked rearward at the burning city.
You mean their mind now
under my responsibility. Yes.
Wolf pulled up a light machine
gun and sprayed the troop. Oops.
Sprayed the group killing
all five prisoners.
The outraged Keating went to
polar and demanded action.
Colonel listened carefully, ordered
wolf arrested and the priest went away.
Content that he had done his duty
10 minutes later. Polar Aston aid.
What outfit was it that lost all those
boys last night? Barrows company, sir.
All right,
give that buy Woolful give that boy
wolf a bar and send him up there.
Okay.
Jones took the story to his cronies as
an example of the military justice at its
best. It spread through the outfit
to become part of the polar legend.
Yeah.
That seems like a pretty
squared away thing to do.
There's like a platoon that's getting
completely destroyed and they've taken a
bunch of casualties and you've got this
kid that did something wrong and we can
arrest him and put him in
prison or whatever, or we
could send them up to fight.
Okay.
Polar sends him up to fight.
In the seven days since d day,
there had been a 1,148 marine casualties,
145 of these killed, 20 more died
of wounds and five we're missing
the North Koreans.
Polar said in his deep drawing voice are
defending the city in such a way as to
force us to destroy it. There's $1
billion worth of publicity and this,
so this is when they're trying to get
into soul and the North Koreans would
offending soul very hard and polar
basically pass to get ultra aggressive
in trying to take sole.
Okay.
Back to the book.
They're fire of artillery and mortars
had set the record for the Korean War.
The four battalions of artillery had
fired all shells at hand and had depleted
in nearby army dump.
At 4.2 mortars had fired 326
rounds and the big 81 650 rounds.
That 50 caliber machine guns had
used 120 boxes or 30,000 rounds.
The night's battle would
put Lieutenant Joe Fisher,
Lieutenant Joe Fisher's
item company to the test.
Fisher dug in for the night on an isolated
hill and the city's factory district
overlooking the roadblock which was on
his left flank from midnight to dawn.
He beat off waves of attack.
Fisher called for artillery.
At the same time, uh,
other frontline commanders asked for help,
but between barrages from the North
Korean swept up Fisher's hill in a bonsai
charges urged by shrill
force commanders in the rear.
Okay.
Item companies,
weapons including machine guns fired
at top speed and bodies piled up them
toward the end.
When the attacks weekend,
the fight turned into a Turkey shoot
and fishers men slaughtered the enemy.
They were glad to see the sunrise.
Fisher never forgot that. Daybreak.
I looked down the hill behind me and saw
man hurrying up towards our position.
I could see that he wasn't lugging any
ammunition and thought it must be an
important message,
too hot for the radio.
Okay.
Then I saw that it was colonel polars
runner and he had brought us a bottle of
black and white scotch.
My God,
where are we glad to see that it was
passed down to the platoon with the most
casualties and they rationed it
out to those who needed it most.
We knew then that the old man was thinking
of us and in fact never forgot us.
Polar came upon marines Duggin around
a barricade taking cover from fire down
the street. He walked among them with
the pipe stub in his mouth, get up, boys,
get up and go. That's the quickest way to
get it over. If you're going to get it,
you can get it in holes
to the line. Moved.
Jo Fisher saw polar in the street.
He was going along where the fire was
heaviest just like he was back in Penelton
as if he didn't know there
was a fight within miles.
I couldn't express how much good it did
me and my troops to see him steady like
that,
just puffing that pipe.
It made us feel like we could do no
less than he did if there's ever been
another one like him in the Marine Corps.
I never saw him in my day.
Bill for Ringo,
the veteran who is the field sergeant
major had a glimpse of the kernel.
It was like going through hell passing
down that sole street and who should we
pass in the middle of it,
but chesty it was so hot that I thought
the grenades and ammunition we carried
would explode. The flames almost met
over our heads from the burning houses,
but the colonel didn't seem
in the least concerned.
It gave us an extra push.
One of the most vague wrap
up this Inchon invasion,
one of the most demanding operations in
marine history. It ended the division.
It's sustained to 2,430 casualties.
414 of them dead of this total,
1064 had been in the last five days in
the streets of Seoul and its outskirts.
Murray's fifth marines had the
worst of it with 1038 casualties,
177 dead polo had a total of 787
with 92 dead Litzenberg 368 72 dead.
Okay.
Polar wrote another letter to his wife.
Everything is quiet now.
I'd have little to do except get
my reports prepared and submitted.
I wish I had a flair for writing as I
as that I am certain this regiment would
get the credit, do them. When the history
of this operation is finally written,
now knows, but in a few years
what is written, we'll govern.
Rest assured that I will do a better job
of getting the facts in my reports that
I did in the past war. I will also
claim everything. Do the regimen.
Many times I've regretted that my English
education was cut short during the
first war.
Please do your best to impress upon
our children the necessity of taking
advantage of every opportunity
in this hard old world of ours.
So he recognized, you know, sad
thing. It's a reality though.
If you're in a leadership
position in the military,
you got to be able to write
well and he regrets that.
He wasn't a little better at it.
So pay attention to the
English class folks.
Yeah,
polar went ashore.
They were back at,
see Pauline went ashore in one of major
Treadwell's landing craft to be met
broadly by a grinning Oliver Smith.
Congratulations Louie. You made it.
Your board is selected you for Brigadier.
Polar wagged his head by God.
If it hadn't been for this war,
I'd never gotten that star.
There was a mild celebration ashore
that night for the new general to be.
So he picked up,
picked up his first star has a general,
and like you said,
if it wasn't for the,
you know,
he'd been put down in some
reserve unit New Orleans.
He wasn't going to make general there,
but case of war break glass.
Now he makes general
polar wrote home daily.
He sent Virginia $5 check for
her good school and Mark A.
Good school marks,
adding some parental advice.
I'm very proud of my family and expect
you to do well plus in everything you
undertake.
The difference between success and failure
in this life of ours is mostly hard
work. So you must constantly
work to try and improve yourself.
I think we can just frame that statement.
On November 10th the
marine corps birthday,
polar used a captured North Korean
store to slice a hundred pound cake.
He shouted to his troops after
he got done delivering the,
um, article from a manual, he shouted out.
Now that that's complied with,
I want to tell you something straight.
Just do one thing for me,
right?
Your people back home and tell him there
was one hell of a damn war going on out
here and that the raggedy tailed North
Koreans have been whipping a lot of so
called good American
troops and may do it again.
Tell them there's no secret
weapon for our country,
but to get hard to get in there and fight,
I want you to make them understand our
country won't go on forever if we stay as
soft as we are now,
there won't be any America because some
foreign soldiers soldiery will invade us
and take our women and a hardier race.
Yeah, there you go.
He's not playing around.
Isn't it interesting that
we hear the same things now?
Like America's getting soft? Polar
was general. Polar was saying
after the marines had taken soul,
the eighth army of the United Nations
forces had driven through the Capitol
moving rapidly northward along
the Korean coast to meet them.
Chinese Communist armories had marched
1800 miles north words since Megan mid
August.
The Chinese strategists at
first concentrated against
the eighth army position
in Northwestern hills,
but when the marines landed,
they heard lead switched much of the power
to meet the o meat and overwhelm them
in the chosen reservoir.
The Chinese drove between the Marines
and the eighth army and maneuvered into
position from which they could
attack each force at will.
So
podcast number 53 colder than hell.
It was about the chosen reservoir.
And there's another one,
I forget the number,
but we've done two podcasts about the
chosen reservoir. Listen to those.
Okay,
touch on it here as well. From the
hills on every side of the perimeter,
Chinese fire was heavy during the day.
The enemy blew a tunnel and a
bridge on the railroad below.
Cota reposition cutting the line to Ha
Hamhung and the Marine base on the sea
for two days.
Polar caller called in heavy air strikes
upon concentrations of Chinese in the
surrounding hills.
Things were even worse than the two
positions to the north of polar.
At least six Chinese divisions had been
identified in the area where Marie and
listened.
Berg fought on November 26th these two
posts lost 95 dead in 543 wounded in
night long attacks hag a room was
preparing to fight for its life and all
offensive launched by the fifth marines
was called off after the day's grim news
from the West.
The eighth army had collapsed,
one wing of it was torn to pieces and
the Chinese were slashing deep into the
lines.
Marines must now defend themselves
in an enemy free against an enemy.
Free to approach from any direction
through the frozen mountains.
The night of November 27th tested the
men at Udab knee when the three Chinese
division divisions fell upon
two marine regiments. The end.
We cut the road to hog guru and sent
their assault battalions in quilted
uniforms and sneakers into the marine
lines with disregard for casualties.
The first waves were driven
off with great losses,
but the others were thrown into,
thrown in through the night and the
next to the dismay of the Chinese
commander's not even the envelopment of
marine command posts slowed the temple
fighting and the American
stage vicious counter attacks.
Even when many platoons had been
reduced to the size of squads,
there were not enough tent for marine
wounded and the less seriously hurt were
piled outside close together
for warmth covered with Straw.
As doctors worked over the
more than 500 casualties
and now became clear that the three
marine positions in the chosen area,
we're surrounded.
Yeah.
Polars reaction to the dread news was
given to newspaper men who flew in to
[inaudible].
Here's what polar said.
We've been looking for the enemy for
several days now. We finally found them.
We're surrounded.
Okay.
That's simplifies our problem with
getting these people and killing them.
Okay.
Yeah. Do you wonder, there's no
wonder why this guy's a legend.
Polar prepared to open the road to
Hungary with Task Force Drysdale,
a British commando unit of Royal Marines
under Lieutenant Douglas Drysdale,
accompanied by Captain Carl Sitters,
company of Ridges Battalion,
and a company from the 31st Army right
army regiment which had come in the road,
had been blocked in several places to
bridges were out and the Chinese swarmed
on heights overlooking the route.
The party met bitter
opposition and within a few,
within a few minutes at 14
casualties in three hours and half,
three hours and a half, they moved
only two miles with eight more to go.
Polar sent tanks as support and men came
down from the hills to walk with them.
They fought through roadblocks
and around a blown bridge,
but at dusk and narrowed defile the met
an ambush and took serious casualties by
radio polar.
Oliver Smith and Drysdale agreed that
the unit must push on to hog or through
whatever the cost.
The Royal Marines finally reached Hogger
route perimeter at 1:30 AM with 90 of
it's 255 men casualties sit or had 63
only 70 of the 210 army men made it
a truck column sent behind this ill fated
party was virtually destroyed after a
long fight and parlay with the Chinese
who captured all the trucks and most of
the men,
the survivors of this party were
crucial to the, to the defense of Haga.
Rune there added firepower, help turn
back another massive Chinese attack.
The companies have sitter and Jo
Fisher killed the enemy in droves.
And by the next dawn there
lines though bent handheld
on the night of December 7th the bulk
of the division was in polars perimeter.
After the 38 hour battle from Haga row,
the 103 dead, 506 wounded, seven missing,
but now the force of 10,000 and it's
1000 vehicles was that [inaudible] the
perimeter could hardly contain them all.
After supper,
the colonel disappeared.
Only Sergeant Jones and I
haven't mentioned much about
Sergeant Jones. He's like,
he's, he's polars right hand man through
this, through all kinds of crazy stuff.
And Sergeant Jones,
only Sergeant Jones knew where he was.
The old man would sneak off with Bodey
and go up into the lion's climbing right
up into those damn straight up hills,
all the ice and rock going from
hole to hole for half the night.
He would go to every man he
could find in a foxhole and say,
how you doing old man? What's your
field of fire? Who's on your flank?
You get enough chow on the way back,
he would check.
The warming tends to see if there'd been
casualties and how the men were doing.
Early on December eight the marines began
clearing the ridges on either side of
the road south,
but the going was slow and the truck's
bearing the bridge sections made little
project progress.
A funeral for 117 marines in a common
grave brought the day to an end in the
perimeter.
Okay.
It was a scene that
lived in polars memory,
the burial of frozen
bodies by a tank battalion,
which crushed them under frozen ground.
Okay.
A marine photographer
took movies of the burial.
Polar said how I wish our people could
have seen this site to see just what
happened to us and Korea.
Yeah.
He later heard that army censorship in
Washington kept the film from the public.
Okay,
and now there
again,
that's very compressed story, but they're
breaking out and they're heading south.
Getting heading back to the sea
and back to safety. Out of the,
out of being surrounded back to the book,
the fifth and Seventh Marines had now
pass through polars ranks in the first was
the rear guard for the entire division
responsible for covering the withdraw
down the frozen loops of the road.
Polar started down and hundreds of men
saw him for he thought that his job had
only be gone.
He shouted to every passing unit to
cheer the men yelling until he was horse.
Don't forget that your first marines,
not all the communists
and hell can overrun you.
Okay?
Okay.
When he got back,
reporters found him and they wanted
a statement from him and he said,
remember, whatever you
write, this was no retreat.
All that happened was we found more
Chinese behind us then in front of us.
So we about faced and attacked.
Smith recommended polar for a navy cross
for his work in the reservoir campaign.
His fifth and the Marine Corps record
pullers letter to his wife revealed his
unusual concern for his family in the
midst of the campaigning.
Please tell Lewis that's his son.
Please tell Louis that I will finally
come home and teach him how to shoot and
many other things that
boys and men must know.
Tell him to be patient and the swords
and the helmet I sent him will arrive.
Tell him to change his bait in
the rabbit trap every few days.
A piece of Apple Lettuce,
carrot, celery, turnip,
and he must not go near the trap or touch
it except to change the bait when the
doors sprung. Also, we must
keep the dog away from it
to what he's telling his boy.
Okay.
He continues on in a letter to his wife.
I haven't minded the hardships here,
but the killing and crippling of young
men is awful due to the weather or
wounded, die blood plasma freezes
before it can be administered.
I realized that this war is for harder
on you than it has beyond me than it has
been on me and I'm sorry to have
caused you all the worry and pain.
Then he goes on to say the Pentagon is
largely responsible for this mess out
here. They weren't even given. They were,
they were given the money to
provide us and train an army.
When I entered the service,
the regulation stated that the object
of all military training is success in
battle.
This short sentence has been rewritten
on three pages and I defy anyone to read
over three or more times and then
explain to me what the object of military
training is.
Even the Pentagon has not the slightest
idea why they are commanding forces of
the United States.
In fact,
out here we wonder if we are
part of the United States
and here he talks about his son again,
tone his wife. I will not influence.
My son has to choosing a profession.
It will be up to him.
I will not even recommend the service.
Yeah.
I've had to stand with my mouth closed
on too many occasions and then carry out
orders from too many halfwits.
Okay,
so as much as he loves the Marine
Corp and the military and the country,
he's saying, look, I might not even,
I'm not going to even
recommend that my son joins.
He gets his painting of his star.
Finally,
he's actually being officially made
a general and he makes a speech.
All the credit for this star belongs
to the non coms junior officers and
enlisted men.
You all know that.
I've tried to do my duty but we'd never
get anywhere except for you fellows in
the ranks.
This is a great regimen and it's going
to hurt me to leave you.
I'll never forget you.
Okay.
To the man of task force polar,
he also issued a formal memorandum
in compliance with orders.
I am today leaving this command for
assignment as division commander,
assistant division commander.
It is not without misgivings and a
certain reluctance that I carry out these
orders.
Okay.
All of you officers and men alike realize,
I am sure what the First Marine
regiment has meant to me.
Okay.
I ask one more thing of you give my
successor the same full measure of
cooperation and willingness you have
always given me and the first marines will
be worthy of the name.
It has already won.
Okay.
I first commanded you on new Britain
later on the bloody hills of Pell Lou and
it is my and has been my honor to command
you in Korea where by your deeds you
captured the city of Seoul,
then successfully covered the withdrawal
of our division from the chosen
reservoir area.
Okay.
I shall look to future to your future
movements and shall expect to hear and see
still greater deeds and higher reputation.
One on the field of battle.
I talked a little bit about,
okay.
The dichotomy in his reputation
polars reputation grew among the men,
but Sergeant Jones noted that the
old man was regarded as a man eater.
Yeah.
They would ask Bodie and me over and over,
how the hell we kept our stripes.
They thought he chewed on people all
the time and when there was a fight,
recklessly exposed his people.
Okay.
And of course we knew better.
It was hard to convince guys
who had heard so much about him,
but didn't really know him.
Okay.
When you got close to him, you found
he had a heart as big as all outdoors.
Okay.
They continued to not make
friends up the chain of command.
We can't help to win.
We can't hope to win future wars and we
got the hell beat out of us and Korea,
unless we have discipline and it's
going to take some brutality to get it.
Okay.
His last days in Korea were frustrating
to Paula who found things suddenly
different. He wrote his wife. Now,
age has probably changed me
and the core has changed too,
I suppose too, man,
being what he is today,
I never thought this change
could or would happen.
Maybe I have been wrong
from the beginning.
No,
he gets back to America and of course
there's a big bunch of reporters waiting
for them and they kind of know
the kind of know he's got a
a mouth, right. So they're, they're
fired up to talk to them and
he's starts talking to the
reporters and here we go.
What the American people want to do
is fight a war without getting hurt.
You can't do any good.
You can't do that any more than you can
go into a bar room brawl without getting
hurt, unless the American people are
willing to send their sons out to fight an
aggressor. There's just not
going to be any United States.
A bunch of foreign
soldiers will take over.
Yeah.
Air Power can't live up to its
billing out here, somebody,
not so much the aviators as the aircraft
manufacturers has sold the American
people a bill of goods as to what air
power can do. From what I've seen,
one bomb,
we'll hit a section of railroad track
and 100 bombs will miss some of them by
miles.
The enemy puts Cooley's on the track
with picks and shovels and in 24 hours
they're rolling again.
The answer is infantry.
Okay.
Our officer core has,
has had far too much schooling and
far too little combat experience.
They can't warn learn war like that push
button war is this far off as in the
days of Julius Caesar,
the rifle,
hand grenade and band net are
still the most important weapons.
We are going to lose the next
war if we don't get back to them.
Why half our infantry out there is still
armed with carbines against the enemy,
with their fine Russian rifles.
Yeah.
He then turned on the training
give marines which could be,
which he would soon be
conducting at Camp Pendleton.
We've got to get them tougher to
survive for all these girls out of camp.
Get rid of the ice cream and candy.
Get some pride in them.
That's what we need most of all pride.
A reporter piped up.
What do you think of the protest of the
women's Christian Temperance Union over
sending free beer to the troops?
It's news to me, Paula said,
but if a few cans of beer or a snort of
whiskey will make the men fight better,
it might not be a bad idea.
At least it's better than ice
cream and all this soft training.
Okay,
there's too much damn recreation
and military training.
We should have only one
purpose to fight and win.
Okay?
They're not being taught that now.
So he's an outspoken guy.
He was astonished the next day
to see the following headlines.
Major General wants beer and
whiskey for the troops. Ice Cream,
Gis, lambasted, bipolar marine
general blast, the air force,
the fewer reached across the nation.
And there was actually protests
against general polar. Uh,
here's, here's, they've actually put
one of these letters in the book.
We hereby petitions.
This is sent to the,
to the government or to the Pentagon.
We hereby petition do you to use every
ounce of influence that you possess to
keep brigadier general
polar from inaugurating,
his beer and whiskey campaign
and US military training camps.
But the,
uh,
the panic did die down and he got
to the business of training marines.
And
in August of 1953 polar took examinations
for major general. That's two star.
The board,
which chose the new group of officers
of rank approved him unanimously.
In July of 1954, he was sent to
Camp Lajune to lead second division.
His first major piece time troop command.
MMM.
There was a little,
uh,
an incident health issue and one of
the guys called up Virginia polar,
his wife and said, brace yourself.
We've taken Lewis to the hospital.
They can't say what's wrong.
He looks pretty sick
and
he basically,
he gets pretty sick.
He kind of recovers from it.
But the, like I said,
this guy made enemies.
So here we go back to the book
and this is polar talking.
I could see then what the game was. They
were going to retire me despite all the,
all the doctors had said
back at lunch at noon,
they'd pulled me up to
Washington to get rid of me.
I didn't mind retiring all that much,
but the way they did it made me sore.
I had all the service and
honors I needed or wanted,
I'd come all the way from
private to major general,
but I was boiling mad about this thing.
I saw lots of officers around
Washington in poor condition than I was,
but that wasn't going to matter.
He remained in the hospital and the
Festa for about two weeks after many
consultations,
the doctors found him unfit for duty.
He wrote his wife daily from his room
on the 16th floor, please do not worry.
We must take things as they come in life.
There doesn't seem much we
can do to change events.
So yeah, just to tell that story
a little more. He had like a,
some kind of health as it was,
I don't know what it was and they
didn't really seem to know what it was,
but then he kind of recovered from it
and he back in his job and then they
pulled them up to Bethesda and to give
them a bunch of screenings and tests and
see if he was fit for duty and they
found that he was unfit for duty.
So that's it. That's how it ended.
That's how his career ended.
A day or so before he went out.
There was a party in the noncommissioned
officers' club on polar had declined an
offer from the officer's club,
but he could not turn the enlisted men.
It began as an intimate party,
but when polar arrived,
he found a crowd of more than
5,000 who'd come to say goodbye.
20 pigs were barbecued and there was
feasting and drinking until late in the
night.
The general made one of his shirt burst
talks when they shouted for him and
Sergeant Orval Jones remembered
it. He said, only men,
I'd rather be toting a rifle and a rear
rank than going out now as lieutenant
general. Now if you're a
marine, you're all marine.
You'll put the core above your family,
your country,
even God and all else.
In some cases you stick to your core.
God bless you.
Polar had broken tradition to the last.
It was unwritten regulation
that the senior marine
officer on the post would pin
polars third star on his
shoulder as he retired,
but polar had called for Bob Norris,
the senior noncommissioned officer and
the oldest man available who had served
with him.
The reporter who followed him got a
formal statement and having sergeant major
norish attach my third
star at my retirement.
I wanted to show my great admiration
and appreciation to the enlisted men and
junior officers of the Marine Corps.
I fully realize that without
the help of the enlisted men,
I'd never have risen from
private to lieutenant general.
I've commanded to everything from a squad
to a division and without the help of
men and junior officers,
these units would never have gone forward
and achieve their objective regardless
of almost certain death.
My only regret is that things now are,
I will not be present for the next or
I also want to express my regret at the
deaths of many hundreds of marines
and the crippling and maiming of other
hundreds who followed
me blindly into battle.
Again,
I would like to thank all marines
for their feelings toward me.
Louis polar went home to Virginia.
It was just 37 years,
four months and two days since he had
boarded the train in South Carolina for
South Carolina to exchange the uniform
of a Vmi Cadet for that of a Marine Corps
boot.
But his career with the
Marines wasn't quite over.
Back to the book.
On a dimly lit night of April 8th,
1956 a platoon of marine recruits
at Parris Island, South Carolina,
was marched into a title arm of broad
river by 31 year old veteran drill
instructor,
Staff Sergeant Matthew c McCune.
Six recruits drowned.
The commandant,
General Randolph Mccall Pate immediately
relieved the commanding officer of the
recruit depot and told
Congress that McCune would be
punished to the full extent
allowed by our uniform
code of military justice.
There was a nationwide outcry from
the press pulpit and scores of civic
organizations. A court inquired choir.
He descended upon Parris Island.
Mccune became a national
cause to celebrate a sailed
by prohibit prohibitionists
as a brutal drunkard,
as a symbol of military tyranny,
which must be destroyed as a
racist bigot. Near Do. Well,
there were cries for harsh punishment,
even execution.
Okay.
Now he ends up going to
trial and for this trial,
the defense brings in
chesty puller per we know,
believes in hard training.
And here we go.
This is a court scene.
Berman,
who's the lawyer use the general like a
master showman that offense desires to
call to the stand.
A lieutenant general polar.
Okay.
Seven years. One of the lawyers, sir.
How do you know the accused polar?
I don't know him except by his pictures
in the newspapers and what I've read
about him than Berman
took over in question.
The general about his career as a Marine
Berman. How long were you in Korea?
Polar? About nine months.
Berman, were you in combat?
Yeah. Where you decorated? Yeah.
Without going into any other,
any of your other decorations,
isn't it true that you've received
five Navy crosses? Correct.
Okay.
Berman asked his opinion of
the Marine Corps' mission.
The definition of military
training is success in battle.
Okay.
In my opinion, that is the only
objective of military training.
It wouldn't make any sense to have a
military organization on the backs of the
American taxpayers with
any other definition.
I believe that ever since
I was been a marine.
Okay.
What is the most important element of
that training? I'll quote Napoleon.
He stated that the most important thing
in military training is disciplined
without discipline and army becomes a mob.
Okay.
Now then in that context,
can you tell us whether you have an
opinion based on your experience as to
whether or not the training and discipline
is for all situations confined to
lesson plan or syllabi or
training regulations? No.
The training of a basic
marine is conducted almost
entirely outside in the field
on the drill ground, on the
rifle range, that kind of work.
The marine gets an idea of how the
Marine Corps run during this training,
but it's training is outside work.
Yeah.
Can you tell us general of the things
you learned here as a recruit? Well,
the main thing that I've remembered all
my life is the definition of a spree
decor. Now, my definition,
the definition I was taught that have
always believed in is that a spree decor
means love for one's military legion. In
my case, the United States Marine Corps.
I also learned that this loyalty to one's
corps travels both ways up and down,
and he continued through this trial and
that night he went to the enlisted man's
club and big crowd of course was there
and they start shouting and yelling for
him to speak and finally he stands up
and says, I've talked enough for today.
This will be my last request.
Do your duty.
And the Marine Corps will be as great as
it has always been for another thousand
years.
Yeah,
the applause was deafening.
Okay.
Went back to his hometown of Saluda
and he was not forgotten there.
There he was getting interviewed
by a graduate student
who is trying to learn about
psychology and the general said,
I've never studied psychology.
I had only one year of college and
always thought I would go back,
but enlisted instead.
I think the Marine Corps is the
best place to learn the art of war
and then again, this
reflects back, you know,
people now say that America is getting
soft and the youth are so they're saying
the same thing.
Everything's going bad and that they
have a panel of experts to deal with the
decline of the nation and it's a
rising tide of juvenile delinquency.
The consensus,
the consensus was that the country
was going to hell in a hand bucket.
General polar while this big meeting
is going on, general polar stood
and intended in his intended mildness
of tone as usual came forth as a brazen
war.
I want you people to know something.
As long as we can get some
decent leadership in our country,
our youth of today will be better men
than their fathers or grandfathers.
I saw enough in Korea to make sure that
our forefathers at valley forge have
been mentioned here tonight
as they often are. Well,
I can tell you that valley forge was
something like a picnic compared to what
your younger Americans went through at
the chosen reservoir and they came out of
it fine.
It was never anything like 25
below zero at valley forge either.
I admit, we don't seem to have
the proper leadership at the top,
but there's nothing wrong
with the kids today.
My wife and I follow the ideas
my mother used on her kids,
making them study each night after this,
after supper,
and when they report that they have
mastered their lessons, quizzing them,
our children don't need to be
coddled and shouldn't be condemned.
Above all,
for Heaven Sakes,
let your son's alone and
let them grow up to be men.
It's interesting that
I would say that still
applies in very many ways.
He also had people visiting him all the
time and asking him questions and he
was, again, he remained speak, you
know, uh, uh, an outspoken guy.
I'm afraid we haven't recognized the
most important lesson from Korea.
The communists have developed a
totally new kind of warfare, uh,
warfare of whole peoples. And under
that no modern nation can be conquered.
We saw something like that in China when
Japan was nibbling away at the mainland.
The Japanese controlled only a square
yard where a soldier stood and nothing
beyond that. In Korea,
the reds improved on that.
This is total warfare,
yet small in scope and it's designed
to neutralize our big nuclear weapons.
Look at Vietnam. The French
outnumbered the communist two to one.
Yet they were massacred.
If we don't design some way to meet this,
they'll whip us in the end.
Don't forget that regular armies
of never fared well in red,
irregular warfare and that
lesson was old when Rome fell.
It's amazing that he's saying this.
It's just, it's just a mandate. We do.
You know the French had been beat.
We hadn't eat,
I don't think we're even in Vietnam yet.
In fact,
we weren't Vietnam yet when this,
when he's making these statements,
we didn't pay attention to it.
Finally,
he goes to a,
and there was some kind of a rift
between him and the First Marine Division
Association and they sorted out that
rift and he went to a big reunion of the
Marine Corps,
the First Marine Division Association,
back to the Book General Smith blinked
against the spotlight and turn to the
blackness.
At the far end of the table.
I now give you chesty and they'll rare.
The roar was so loud,
it drowned out the speaker's
voice and shook the walls.
The spotlight swung to the last place
at the table to reveal polar in a linen
suit, waving his hand and
flashing his broad crooked grin.
As the clamor increased,
he marched to the microphone and
started a in a bobbing circle of light.
General Smith shouted to the
tempest of the sound. I see.
You all know chesty puller.
Men in the crowd danced among the tables
world each other about and pounded
their neighbors on the backs.
Some climbed on their chairs shouting
wordlessly tears streaming on their
tricks.
Others hammered the table with cutlery
or embraced women who were staring
incredulously at polar.
Okay.
The men broke into chance. We
want chesty. We want polar.
They called for a speech,
but it was almost five minutes
before the howling ceased.
Polar face them with a wry smile that
looked as if it had been rung from his
face by force.
When quiet returned,
he grasped the microphone and called an
an astonishing leap. Penetrating voice.
Marines.
Pandemonium broke out once more as if
he had shouted some secret watch word
whose implications were
known only to these men.
Half the crowd was still on its feet a
moment later when polar could be heard
again.
Okay.
If you believe the newspapers
and radios and television,
our country is in a hell of a shape.
Okay.
I don't believe it. So long as
we've got the first marine division,
we'll be okay.
The crowd shouted him into silence again.
He was tired when he got home
to Saluda and that evening,
Virginia polar found him pensive
and distractive, distracted.
They sat on the screened porch looking
out into the Virginia dusk lit by
fireflies.
Louis,
is there anything you'd wish
for now that it's all over?
Well, he said I'd like to do it
all over again. The whole thing.
She side
more than that,
more than anything.
I'd like to see the face once again
of every marine I've ever served with,
and that
is where this book ends.
But that is not where
this story ends because
as I mentioned then as the book mentioned,
Chesty Puller had a son.
Okay.
And his son also became
a Marine Corp officer,
but his son's experience in the Marine
Corps in combat and in life was very
different from his father's
good.
I will tell that story
in the next episode,
number 122 which is available now
so you can listen to it immediately
because these
stories are linked
and so we are linking them
in this series of podcasts.
And in the meantime,
before you listened to that Echo,
if somebody wants to support this podcast,
can you briefly tell us how
we can do it? Yes. Okay.
Briefly we'll talk about the store Jocko
store. That is where you can get this.
Blink was freedom shirts,
hats,
some rash guards on their hoodies
and beanies are on the way.
Promise, um, if not already, uh, just,
you know, check on that Jocko, store.com.
There's a lot of good stuff on there for
women and also kid stuff where your kid
stuff.
Also when you get the book
marine life of Chesty Puller a,
I'm going to list it on the website
in the book section, it's on the top.
You Click there,
it says books from episodes and I'll
have them all listed by episode.
Click through that good way to support,
uh,
it take you to Amazon and you get
your book and get whatever else you're
shopping for.
Also,
go to origin main.com. This is where you
can get your g if you're doing Jujitsu.
When you do Jujitsu is where you
can get you all made in America.
There's also rash guards on there and
there's some hoodies and sweatpants
and stuff on there. Very comfortable.
Uh, I went over that before.
But um, nonetheless, go there.
[inaudible] dot com also
or did you mean.com still?
You can get Tacos,
supplements. We have milk.
That's the new one. Is that available
yet? Yes. Boom. There you go. Well,
protein powder, mint chocolate
chip. That's the good one.
Tastes good too.
What else tastes good is Jocko discipline,
which is a nootropic
pre mission supplement.
Good. Little bit of caffeine in there. Not
Too much a little bit, but for, you know,
it has the physical,
a supplementation benefits and the
cognitive supplemental benefits.
So get down called discipline. Also
joint warfare. And krill oil, Jocko,
Super Krill oil. These supplements are for
your joints. Don't neglect your joints.
It's a big deal.
You can be able to lift 500 pounds,
but if your elbows are jacked up,
you're not going to be up
to lift that 500 pounds.
Maybe you get a warm up a bunch,
but I know it'll mess you up if you're
going to mess up. It's a big deal. Anyway,
take her joints.
Super Krill and joint warfare
all made America. By the way.
Everything in origin mean made in America.
Also for fitness gear like kettle bells,
the cool ones.
I get primal bells.
It's actually a lot of good stuff
on on it.com go slash Jocko.
Good way to support good
workout gear on there. Also,
if you want Jocko white tea,
I'm going to put that in the store.
I think make it easy,
but it's everywhere.
Jocko white tea you can get on Jocko,
store.com I'll put down there soon.
If not right now,
Amazon of course,
and you can go to Jocko t.com
that's kind of the main hub.
And then so if you're shopping
international, it'll direct,
direct you to where you can get it.
I think that's what I'm putting in the
store so we can ship it to Canada and
stuff. There was a whole thing. Anyway,
I'm gonna make it easy. Um, yeah,
so actually go to [inaudible] dot com
that'll direct you to where ever you,
you are in however you, however you want
to get it. Also subscribe to the podcast.
If you haven't already on
iTunes, stitcher, Google, play,
Spotify, wherever, wherever
they have a podcast.
Subscribe. Good way to support also
youtube video version of this podcast.
Also excerpts,
little lessons kind of just taken from
each episode and enhanced excerpts.
If you're, if you're really into
feeling the message, just doctor,
her mom was the music or something
like that. Also, psychological warfare.
If you don't know what that is,
it's an album with tracks Jocko
telling you pragmatic advice,
how to get through moments of weakness
in your campaign against weakness.
Like workouts.
Like if you want to skip the workout
or you want to slip on the day just a
little bit, just refer to one of the
tracks in there. Jack would tell you,
you know,
hold the line
as they say,
check and you know,
speaking of subscribe and subscribing,
we have a new podcast out and it's,
it's actually separate from this podcast.
The new podcast is called the war.
Your kid podcast, ask Uncle Jake.
Like I said, it's a separate channel, so
you have to subscribe to it separately.
I did that because as you know
from listening to this podcast,
there's some podcasts that are for very
mature audiences and you wouldn't want
to have your kid listening to
that, you know, a kid podcast.
Then all of a sudden a very
violent podcast comes on.
So we separated them,
the warrior kid podcast
questions for Uncle Jake and
yeah,
I think uncle Jake has lessons for
everyone regardless of age. Yeah.
You know,
I think teachers and parents and big time
would want to listen to that as well.
Yeah, we've got some great
feedback so far on it.
So that's called the warrior kid podcast.
And on top of that, there's a new war.
Your kid book, it's called Mark's
mission. If you actually want it,
you should order it now through whatever
channel you want to order it from.
Go to your local bookstore,
go to Amazon, go to and noble,
order it so that you have it when it
comes out so that the publisher knows how
many to make because otherwise the
publisher thinks, oh well we'll,
we won't make that many of them because
there's not that many people that you
know are going to buy this. They're wrong
because you all are going to buy this.
So if they don't know that
they don't make enough,
it takes too long to get it once
it comes out. So order it now.
Other books you can order.
Extreme ownership,
combat leadership for business and life
discipline equals freedom field manual.
It's about getting after it and actually
Leif Babin and I have a new book coming
out, a follow up to treme ownership.
It's called the dichotomy of leadership.
It is available for preorder right now.
Same thing.
Order it now so that you get
your copy when it comes out.
Otherwise you'll be waiting.
Okay.
I have a leadership and
management consulting company.
It's called Ashkelon Front.
If you want information about that,
go to Ashkelon front.com
we have the muster,
which is a leadership conference
coming up. If you want to come to it,
go to extreme ownership.com and also
if you want to attend the roll call,
which is for military law
enforcement, firefighters, paramedics,
other first responders.
If you want to do that,
you can also sign up for the roll
call@extremeownership.com and with that,
as I just mentioned,
these podcasts,
these three podcasts that we're
doing right now are all linked.
It's one big story with a thread running
through it and we are releasing them
all at the same time.
So the next one will be one 22 and one
23 go ahead and and go listen to them
right now.
And until then,
this is echo and Jocko out.